two
guys welcome it is friday baby
24.
[Applause]
forgive me for being so late it's my
birthday okay cut me some slack
it's the my birthday bonanza
i don't know what you guys have planned
but i walked in and there was like
something of me hanging from the roof
which leads me to believe you guys are
gonna like burn me an effigy
burning man ethan edition am i the man
just have to wait and find it i'm
guessing
ethan klein oh thank you
that was very nice
but any guy anyway anywho welcome guys
welcome whoa look at love
oh is he doing the uh
mid-summer mid-summer
oh yeah isn't that the fertility thing
are you feeling fertile today
i think it is yeah there's some
fertility going on with that dude
we're just celebrating the middle of the
summer
we're all happy
uh i think you're supposed to knock
someone up bro
okay bro don't make you weird okay i did
okay all right sorry i'm not kidding uh
but this right here is uh
like a big thing that you dance around
and you sing happy frog or small frogs
it goes like smokey or nasty
[Laughter]
uh
welcome welcome everybody thank you to
hello fresh for sponsoring us today
we have a lot of great stuff besides the
fact that uh
today in america if you care about such
things oh gabe
gabe what's going on buddy
happy birthday ethan happy earth
birthday ethan [ __ ] yeah thanks buddy is
that tito's is that straight cheetos
that's a big shot there dude
you turning up for me sure why not
all right special birthday
thanks nobody
but the best ethan they're the best
nobody like you eat that because you're
the bro you too man you're the best
there's nobody like you gabe
yeah oh oh oh oh oh oh oh this is an
honor if you eat that thing because
you're the best because you deserve the
best
[ __ ] baby thanks baby
[Music]
oh my
[Applause]
and other social media platforms that
you're the best ethan
thanks bro you know i've always got your
back
um
our successes are tied together without
each other we're nothing right gabe oh
yeah
we help each other yeah we promote each
other i help you exactly that's it we we
together
[ __ ] [ __ ] baby
[Music]
dick in my butt [ __ ]
you can't get my butt i got you with
that one good bottom
kicking my butt [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right so what do you got planned
today you're going to be just hanging
out doing a barbecue what's the deal
what it's a natural holiday right
ethan's birthday yeah next week baby
what's next next week is 4th of july 4th
of july dang i didn't even realize you
got all the holidays on lockdown man
if i become president gabe you'll be my
secretary of holidays
sure why not yeah i can change the days
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
gabe if you could add one national
holiday what would it be
i'd say gabe's day gabe's day gabe's day
what day is that on oh november 18th
gabe's day november 18th and what do you
do on gabe's day to celebrate
whoo
gonna have a party and some strippers
baby oh yeah game day friday and
november 18th we gotta write that down
gabe's day baby [ __ ] [ __ ] my
dick [ __ ]
my dick [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hey guess what uh day november 18th uh
2022 is on what's that it's
[Applause]
all right gabe you have a great day i
want to say one thing
[ __ ] oliver retreat i want to fight that
[ __ ] that's right
right okay right right okay thanks bro
yeah i appreciate you
having my back on that huh
[Laughter]
all right
all right yeah all right gabe take care
buddy love you have a great friday okay
yeah you have a great one
thanks for the birthday wishes buddy
happy birthday ethan best wishes thanks
bro you're the best you're the greatest
white claw gave everybody
white clock gabe he's on cameo he's on
tick-tock
he's everywhere
and uh for good reason he is the best
now
um
uh let's see mid-summer celebration in
sweden
is held
during summer time and the season of
fertility
you guys were right yes
you guys know my whole day better than
me apparently yeah you guys even know
that i don't know there's a weird thing
with mid-summer it's like people know
about it for me so who so what are we
doing about the fertility there uh love
we got any plans
of course always about to make me act up
we'll see we'll see we'll see what the
night leads me well let me
good man i'm wishing the best for you
thank you
let me tell you what we got planned here
today obviously our country is doomed
and that's like not that fun of a topic
but it is a topic with the
they've basically made it legal for
states to uh make abortion illegal
roe versus wade
but so there's that and there's uh
what something that i'm really excited
about and this might be the first time
jimmy lee is hearing about it but we did
a loyalty test on jimmy lee where we had
keemstar's producers
reach out and offer him an exclusive
very lucrative show deal
to see if he would take it
we're gonna have the result what time is
he calling in do we have them lined up
2 15 all right so we'll line that up
around
about an hour from now yeah so that
that's pretty exciting guys
i want audio i want to check audio audio
audio
i was pretty surprised by the results of
it i'll be honest i'm ready to be
shocked yeah
and then furthermore we have um
uh
uh whatever who cares
oh this is this the board ape yacht club
we covered it how they're all like
they're apparently like nazis
well one of the board ape people reached
out to me
and has been trying to convince me that
it's all just a big
ruse
so i want to talk about that
conversation i had with the
the board ape guy
this is all the fars
but before that we got some stuff at the
top of the show let's enjoy
we've got some alpha male videos i like
that
how are you eli we haven't checked in
with you in a minute
i'm good
uh
i just did this week christina p's
podcast and i don't know when that's
gonna come out but
not out yet uh
to all the mommies out there if you want
to hear me complain about all kinds of
mommy stuff
oh yeah this is the first time you've
been on because we got banned so i think
it's been a while since you yeah i
haven't been and then there was the
oliver tree bonanza right which was
amazing and i
just was
shocked by all of you guys that you
pulled it off it was yeah it came really
really cool it was fun i died at the end
but yeah that's okay
thank god for my
thank god for the paramedics
and then i see fit check requests
oh go hit check this there's new
overalls that will come out come out in
august okay
that's the conductor coming in
you got those overalls is that church
teddy fresh no this shirt is just
vintage
and um do we see the shoes please
yes
[Music]
had to do it to him show him the soul
[Applause]
you had to do it this gucci adidas
collaboration is
like i died when i saw everything it's
so good can i ask you this is not a
commercial for them i just freaking i
wish you kidding they're not paying us i
love it and like if you if anybody goes
and looks at it in person there's so
much detail it's just like amazing
i was going to ask you
is it really because it just looks like
adidas with the gucci
shoes yeah i mean you it's like it's got
nice materials though but it's not it's
nicer it's like from this one is from
like velvet which the typically this is
not okay i mean i'm not gonna be here
and like justify it too much you gotta
be just like sure you know who the [ __ ]
do that i have regulars
i have regular ones that would cost not
anywhere near these what did what's the
price tag on those uh
i mean regular one would be under 100
and the other is probably like 80. this
one's like add another zero probably oh
out of zero she says i don't know
it's pretty bad but
i sent him
what you said the prices i'm not
i don't know oh let's take a look i'm
not but i think they're all sold out
it's kind of crazy like i wanted to get
a hat just to look at it
and everything's all sold out already
yeah or wait no it's on the website
ah who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] gucci nice
shoes either
i mean you know what i mean
i i didn't need to get into i love
i love adidas i love coaching yeah and i
feel like when you see fans of like two
creators say like this is worlds
colliding it's just kind of like seeing
that happen
and so i i nerd out on it yeah dope
we love that for you
you deserve it
you work hard
and i'm glad you're you're treating
yourself to something good there i want
to smell feet
and as a foot fetishes i get it you want
to drape your feet and sometimes i still
want to clarify that i never said that
well you said i want to smell feet right
i do remember when you said that
actually yeah
so i'm not sure i think it's a.i
no i don't think so we've said we've
analyzed the waveform uh it appears to
be authentic
late again zach i want to smell feet
yeah no that's really you said that i
think we're leaving a simulation
well hold on let's let's analyze it
against jordan peterson's uh go ahead
jordan you should not [ __ ] my dog
i love that yeah please not come on my
dog yeah
it does sound a little go play the whole
thing i didn't know i think anywhere
yeah
i've never done anything weird with my
dogs
right i love it
i don't believe him so much when he
pushes it that
that hard yeah i think jordan [ __ ] the
dog anyway
let's get to the [ __ ] boys
what's up player
oh my god did it switch
did it switch
to a different
video are you saying is this the video
maybe
yeah it started okay okay i was like
what the [ __ ] here we go
hey
it says so i've been doing some thinking
and i think we should end this talking
phase
wow i don't know what to say honestly
i'm shocked
shocked are you serious right now
you're so inconsistent you barely even
talked to me no i'm shocked because i
thought i blocked you last week
i don't have your number saved i blocked
the wrong girl
oh my god joker brand is [ __ ]
now i know why blank hasn't been hitting
me up anymore are you serious right now
what is gmf you
[ __ ] andrew
this is like insult fantasy isn't it
i seriously can't believe you have a
nice little got me [ __ ] up
did you seriously just send me a [ __ ]
game request
yo this is straight in cell fantasyland
poker brand wow it has 400 000 likes so
yeah i mean this is what i'm saying when
i say i'm blackpilled
we just
50 of our of the citizens
of america
just lost the right to govern their own
bodies
and then you have 400 000 likes on this
insult fantasy school shooter thing
and it's it's out of control guys i i
don't know
yeah i'm conflicted because i feel very
happy to be here today and so i want to
like goof around and stuff and then
there's the
there's the other half
that like once we start talking about it
i'm gonna get really upset
well the thing about the uh roe vs wade
is like we all knew it was coming mm-hmm
so it's not a total shock but but it's
official it is well the really [ __ ] up
thing
is that um
who's the dude who's married to the uh
to the uh trump uh insurrectionist oh
clarence clarence yeah so clarence wrote
oh my god so here the supreme court
voted 5-4 to overturn roe versus wade
okay the specific case was voted 6-3
however one justice john roberts did not
vote in favor of overturning so i'm
confused how it did and is it 6-3 or 5-4
it so
the case that was under examination that
led to it being overturned
was
roberts voted in favor uh with all the
other conservative judges but then there
was a further judgment of whether this
overturned the roe precedent and he
said that this was not sufficient to
overturn the road so he in that case
sided with the dissenters but um they
still had the majority you know it's
funny john roberts he's the head justice
he was like appointed by bush he's like
a class of conservative and you can just
see like these new one the new guys in
there the three
uh the trump appointed there are
literally [ __ ]
cult they're part of a they're christian
fascists i mean genuinely and truly they
are and you can see john roberts the old
school conservative is like this doesn't
overturn roe versus wade
but these [ __ ] hard for me to follow
this whole there was one republican that
voted not to overturn rover suede
but it's still 6-3 right
the vote with his vote it was 5-4
um but
obviously that is still enough for it to
be overturned you know it's hard not to
be mad at ruth
whatever ruth gator gator ginsburg
no for not [ __ ] uh they're not
returning the [ __ ] down yeah
yeah god damn what's what old people
need to [ __ ] go away with a little
dignity man the supreme
justices they can step down
yeah they can retire at any time well
usually they do it strategically so like
um
she when obama was president had the
opportunity she was sick she had cancer
she was in the hospital she was old as
[ __ ]
and so usually what happens is they'll
strategically step down when a democrat
is president so he can appoint someone
and what happened is she's like nah i'm
gonna sir i'm gonna keep [ __ ] serving
because i
am [ __ ]
i'm tired of old people [ __ ] ruining
this country that's all that's happening
just just walk away with some grace and
dignity lady you know she worked so hard
she achieved so much in her life and
then like if she would have just you
know retired with some grace this [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] wouldn't be happening
really no
no well that's [ __ ] yeah we would have
a we would have a a sane uh justice in
there and this you know
six
five four would be
five four the other way
i don't get the supreme court it's a
scam
it is we were talking about it yesterday
it's so [ __ ] stupid the lifetime
appointments the lifetime thing it's
such a scam no it's horrible and now
these these these fat these christian
fascists are going to be on the court
for like 50 years of peace they're all
super young
and there's but what what uh that uh
that dude said
clarence whose wife is an
insurrectionist
he wrote in his opinion
that he thinks that they should
re-examine the court rulings
that protect gay marriage and
uh making contraceptives legal yeah this
is just the beginning
obviously
so
like that's it's it's insane bro i don't
know if you're in a red state you're
just go you're like you're just going to
be [ __ ] i have to say i'm i'm fresh
off of giving birth and bring pregnant
so it's it really hits close to me
and i'm just like
furious with every inch
of my body like i
could not go through that against my
wishes
never ever it's impossible you can't go
through that if you don't want to do it
it's
it takes such a toll on you it's hard
beyond like anything you can explain
obviously your whole body goes through
so much and you it'll never be the same
too afterwards and then you have a whole
life that you created well and that's it
and that's only the beginning of it
there's so much to talk about it it's
just insane well that's ignoring if you
were raped by your dad or
and a something horrific
red states are being like nope
even even some racial states like if you
might die you still have to give birth
right i mean there are some that are
being that extreme about it and and then
for this to come off of after the
elementary school shooting yeah yeah and
it's like where is that energy to
protect those kids they don't give a
[ __ ] that doesn't exist but let's
protect unborn
unwanted babies i don't want it if if
the parent doesn't want it who's going
to raise that child
who's going to do that based on like the
one like uh it's
this like newborn christians are like i
wanted to get an abortion but i ended up
giving birth and it was the best thing
that ever happened was like shut up
[ __ ] okay good for you good for you i
don't give a i don't give two [ __ ]
about you
yeah what does that have to do with me
and my body i'm happy for you and your
dumb [ __ ] kid
who's probably gonna be a school shooter
himself
with a mom like you you freak ass jesus
[ __ ] i tell you what jesus rock people's
brains faster than god damn fentanyl
you can do a little jesus that's fine
you know like a micro dose of jesus is
dope right my credit is religion yeah
yeah a micro dose just the feel
just to feel the energy i mean a lot of
people i know are i would probably
describe that like yeah yeah they dabble
in it they believe in the core values
but they're like good-hearted people and
they don't
seek out like
forcing me to get pregnant
yeah if you take too much jesus or god
in general then you're going to have a
bad trip
it's just the so here this is what i
want to read this is the really scary
part so
uh clarence
again who i can't emphasize enough we
talked about yesterday his wife
is literally
an insurrectionist she was in favor of
overthrowing the election in favor of
trump she is a [ __ ] christian fascist
herself
and he's on the supreme court he should
be impeached just for that should have
recused himself
but here so so clarence says we need to
look at griswold versus connecticut
this is basically the constitutional
protection
for married couples to buy and use
contraceptives without government
restriction now why the [ __ ] would you
want the government to intervene a
contraceptive you sick
freaks so he wants to go he wants to
make contraceptives illegal
he goes and then lawrence versus texas
he wants to re-examine that sanctions of
criminal punishment for those who commit
sodomy
uh
just being gay
gay sex essentially so he he he wants to
make
he wants to make gay sex illegal
potentially in red states
he really said we should examine this
one
uh-huh
did he did he rationalize that at all or
would they just say i want to look at
these ones well their rationale is
always um well not always when it's
convenient the rationale is always that
the federal government shouldn't be the
ones making these decisions and it
should be left to the states
except
when it's not like except decisions
exactly that's what i was about to say
[ __ ] hypocrite [ __ ] dude
yeah so he wants to make gay sex illegal
oh there's a lot of straight couples
that enjoy uh sodomy
as well i will say yeah i believe sodomy
technically is any sexual act other than
like missionary sex base it's just butt
sex no anal sex i think oral sex is
considered sodomy as well like
dictionary definition
oh you're right it says sexual
intercourse involving anal or oral yeah
clarence you don't want any more
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] and it's a sexual
dance
dude you're [ __ ] dude you guys you
guys are going to hell bro none of the
people that make the rules are going to
live by the rules by the way hell no
republicans those those they got a
private christian fascists be getting
abortions like a damned tic tacs
popping those [ __ ] with all their
mistresses
and then uh finally
uh
obergefell versus hodges that he wants
to take us another look at the
fundamental right to marry is guaranteed
to same six couples
by both the due process clause and the
equal production clause of the 14th
amendment
so he wants to undo that one as well
cool
and i mean if that happens if if they
really go that route then
so like we live in a democratic
area what what are the chances yeah blue
state what are the chances that's going
to change here or not democratic i mean
yeah yeah no chance no nothing will
change here but what about mr [ __ ]
caruso
he's the la mayor he can't do [ __ ] you
know
but no no
nothing will change in california but if
you go to texas for example or some [ __ ]
ass oklahoma
then they're going to be like
um
they'll be like um no abortions
no gay sex
no gay marriage
but as many guns as you want that's
going to be the utopian conservative
youtuber
here are uh so these states that are
highlighted are the ones that already
have what they call trigger laws
regarding abortion they're ready to go
yeah so essentially have you know as of
today
uh
have implemented that so there are 22
states with such laws well the most
extreme of them is makes it like super
illegal for anyone to do it women who
are who are at risk of dying
or the babies at risk or the baby super
chat right now said the baby is born
with like extreme uh health conditions
and is not likely to die or even if the
baby is stillborn
this one yeah i read this donation
you read it i it's hard to find okay i
got pregnant at 16 and unfortunately the
baby had no heartbeat
it was it was considered an abortion to
have it removed this is going to kill
women yeah yeah yeah
yes it's going to kill women
and destroy lives
but
at the end of the day
you really are just talking about
someone's control over their own [ __ ]
body i mean it's insane
it's insane
and it's only affecting
women
um sarah's donated ten dollars thank you
i work in peds cata cardiology we see
fetuses who have serious congenial
disease who will not live outside of the
womb those moms want the babies but get
abortions because it's what's best for
the kid and now yeah these babies are
going to be born into a short life of
pain and misery for them and the family
it'll be illegal i mean what the [ __ ]
are we doing dude
so can all the normal people who don't
believe in this [ __ ]
move out of those states and then can
all those people in those states own
guns and just like shoot each other
and then do we clear everything clear
the problems that way
well people can leave if they want but
it's not that easy especially if you're
poor yeah i mean california is very
[ __ ] expensive new york all the most
of the democratic states are really
expensive
and just moving itself is disruptive and
maybe you know you have family or
connections to your home that you don't
necessarily want to leave you like that
state otherwise you know it's
it's not easy yeah yeah
well yeah and well what's really crazy
is that the majority of people i'm
talking like a vast majority of people
are not in favor of this [ __ ] in the
whole throughout the country and that's
why it's christian fascism just like
with the gun gun control yeah totally
it's christian fascism in that it's a
minority of radical [ __ ] freaks that
are having this country in a
stranglehold
i just don't understand it because even
israel who is a country that is half
like the government is half religious
you know it's not completely secular
you can do abortions like
this is considered very primitive
even in israel
yeah i don't get it
uh 20 bucks uh oreo oh that's the legend
who keeps don't buying members isn't
that yep recent uh south carolina
decision includes border patrol swat can
operate above the law 100 miles from a
border international airport and coast
cops don't have to read miranda rights
illegal abortion seems like a very very
sus string of decisions yeah that border
control one is insane too because
basically that's like what 80 percent of
the
of the population live within
one border or another yeah
yep yep and you know what you know one
thing that really pissed me off
and they're not doing it intentionally
but there's a lot of people that still
describe
uh
forced to birth people as like
um pro-life like they're using that or
or anti-choice or whatever
dude the fact that they've that they've
created this conversation
and the two sides they've actually
positioned themselves correctly as
pro-life is [ __ ] insane we need to
call it forced birth we need to call it
what it is they're not pro-life that's
[ __ ] that's an insane euphemism for what
they're doing like we've got to start
calling it forced birth it's that insane
it's that barbaric that's what it is
nobody should give them the benefit of
the doubt to call them anti-choice or
[ __ ] uh pro-life that that's
outrageously insane it's [ __ ]
pathetic
jesus christ dude
attracted a ghost said i have a rare
genetic condition called ip
that causes the baby to die if it's a
male
i used to be from a red state and today
has been devastating
whoa that's crazy
blue states aren't necessarily safe
if there is a republican president they
can make a nationwide abortion ban well
you gotta love that that they can do
that but they can't ban guns or you know
like
our president can't do [ __ ] apparently
i find it unlikely there be a nationwide
ban because they just ruled that it's
the state's decision
like that would be utterly
[ __ ] insane
it's like we talked about it recently uh
i forget if it was on leftovers on this
show but um
they'll do it if they want to because
like i was saying the republicans
know how power actually works and the
democrats are too afraid to actually
wield it
that's what they want that is the end
goal
and even if it seems on the surface like
well they can't do that because that's
contradictory to what they just said
that doesn't matter well yeah they did
that with um
when they when obama got his pick
for a supreme court they go
dude it's hard i can't even rehash that
[ __ ] it's so [ __ ] up the the democrats
are so spineless they are so pathetic
they are the biggest [ __ ] losers the
people like nancy pelosi only care about
insider trading and and maintaining the
status quo she's a [ __ ]
and she's so old just go [ __ ] away yo yo
yo yo
go easy on pelosi dude [ __ ] pelosi did
you hear the poem she read this morning
hold that [ __ ] up i wanna [ __ ] die
yeah i mean you gotta see these boomer
ass pieces of [ __ ] dude they went out on
the steps and started singing like
christmas carols that poem will make me
feel so much better she could serve that
poem up her goddamn ass there you go uh
look at this [ __ ] okay here's nancy
pelosi
you dumb [ __ ] you stupid all she does is
inside trade that's it
she's a criminal she's a criminal her
husband
she gives her husband is the most
successful stock trader of all time okay
is that it are you exact is that hyper
no no it's not hyperbolic really google
it he's he is the most successful
stock trader ever
wouldn't that be warren buffett or he
doesn't do it yeah that's what it makes
well in terms of like um just returns
like in terms of like the amount of
investments that pay off or something
look it up it's insane it's it's pul
title yeah yeah like and they've been
doing this for years and years and years
you know it's funny they all
consistently
the people are like you guys in senate
should not be able to buy and trade
stocks or anyone in congress you are
your spouse actually coincidentally some
breaking news about uh nancy pelosi's um
husband have you seen did he [ __ ] die
oh
too bad
just a dui charge got charged with dui
yesterday nice
[ __ ] wet reckless
we're not a lawyer for you
on the line what an [ __ ] was he way
over or just a bit over uh
let's see
i know he was it was a napa he was
leaving one of his vineyards or
something like that he was right oh it
was at a vineyard his vineyard he was
exactly 0.08 which in california is the
limit so he had like a glass of wine so
it's not
um probably yeah i think he has repeated
duis though what a guy i don't think
imagine being the wife of one of the
most famous uh congresswoman in the
world and just getting a dui because you
don't give a [ __ ] about the law
well of course he doesn't but you know
what um
people keep trying to make it illegal
for congress people just to trade stocks
and of course all the people in congress
people like no we need to be able to do
this we need to be able to partake in
the economy how about you suck my
[ __ ] dick nancy pelosi you dumb old
hag
sorry but that's the way it is
[ __ ] over it dude
well i am personally overwhelmed by this
decision
so anytime i quote
this poem by ahud manor
he's an israeli
poet i met his wife when i've been in
israel
abortions in israel my land is burning
how are you going to talk about the
world in hebrew penetrates my veins my
soul with an aching body and with a
hungry heart
here is my home
i will not be silent
for my country
doesn't even rhyme
it's too embarrassing it's honestly just
making me upset and you know what's
crazy she had like months to prepare
and she busts out this poem
okay
you know what i think it's time
apologies to all the poets out there but
show time to abolish poetry
listen in israel they have abortions but
let's not talk about that let me read
you a poem
it's gonna make you feel so much better
then read it every day during the nine
months you have to carry a baby you
don't want
nancy pelosi already sent her first
fundraising email off roe vs wade let's
go i need your immediate attention
supreme trump supreme court
just ruled to
rip reproductive rights away from every
single woman in this country i don't say
this lately how we act today will decide
the future of reproductive rights we can
either sit back and admit defeat to
these far-right extremists or we can
rise up
we need like some heavy metal and red
like this is something
we can rise up at the voting booth
meet this once in a generation moment a
martial or spot so historic
anti-choice [ __ ] forced to death
don't say anti-choice you dumb [ __ ]
republican regret that they've ever
thought
please i've never missed your support
more than today
can you chip in 15 bucks
so we can win these [ __ ]
midterms and codify reproductive rights
what's that you know i i hate to bring
it up because everyone like thinks
hamilton's so corny but there's a song
in there
right you know how to say goodbye rosa i
love hamilton george washington he
taught him how to say goodbye yeah walk
away with grace nancy you're too [ __ ]
whole everybody's all these dumb [ __ ]
minds
and fig tree
a moment alone in the shade yes yes go
enjoy your billion dollars you dumbag
and read poems every day
go read a [ __ ] poem by yourself in
your damn study
[ __ ] you
and it was used in a book a book yeah
one last time look it up
i just like don't even know what to say
honestly i don't even know what to say
my body is like furious i can tell you
like i just feel like angry
and i don't know what to do about it
i've been getting like chills all
morning yeah
i'm just you know what's crazy and and
it's ask women i think every man
looking at all you guys
need to scream for us because it doesn't
have anything to do with you and it has
everything to do with us and that's such
[ __ ]
looks all of us makes me upset yeah yeah
but it's a bunch of old white dude who
are deciding that you can't it's my body
yeah i will know
that's a life-changing
thing that you're asking a person to do
against their will
well you know what's crazy about nancy
pelosi she really cares about
reproductive rights when it comes to
fundraising but she was just campaigning
for a
forced birth candidate democrat
campaigning hard in which state was it
dan texas yeah she was campaigning hard
for a first birth candidate
so what the [ __ ] are you talking about
like the final poem about that
yeah write a poem about that hag ass
[ __ ] sorry i [ __ ] hate you
i'm pissed off dude and i'm sick of
pretending like this woman's not a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
she is
go away dude go spend time with your
grandkids and [ __ ]
how many how many democrats or or people
in congress in general are like over the
age of 60 95 percent
now 65 that's like when people retire
traditionally you know
i'm sorry okay
listen
you can be old and enjoy your [ __ ]
life
okay
do that
uh the average age of members of the
house is 57.
oh that's an and the average age of uh
the senate is
63. 63.
those [ __ ] are old that's the
average yeah that's the average right
exactly so yeah the average age is two
years before retirement
and as you already pointed out all the
ones that trump appointed are in their
50s so they're below average oh man
they're young they're spry yeah they all
look super healthy none of that who's
that guy who [ __ ] croaked recently
the supreme court justice guy are you
talking about scalia yeah none of them
look like scalia they're healthy as [ __ ]
none of these guys are dying anytime
soon you drank beer we drank beer
senator having some beers with friends
yeah i guess kavanaugh might i'm going
for some liverpool
keep drinking that beer keep drinking
that beer kavanaugh you [ __ ] demon
drink beer
nancy pelosi was born in 1940
[ __ ]
11 years after the depression that is
wild
1940 nancy pelosi was born when [ __ ]
before abraham lincoln died
that's not true
close pretty close
probably were alive at the same time
abraham lincoln nancy pelosi was born
before her dad fought in the civil war
she was born before d-day think about
that
this [ __ ] is old as [ __ ] and i'm sick
of it
damn i support it 1940.
[Music]
put the [ __ ] poem away
and do something
pull up that clip of them singing
christmas carols on the congress steps
dumb [ __ ] wait can i show you my
favorite yeah show me a picture
1940
the [ __ ]
we're just working oh yeah of course
oh yeah i love that one
yeah this this was what were they doing
here just the george floyd memorial yeah
they had actually the lion king play in
the background
that scarf is really moving god damn it
i was
touched get out
pull up the damn christmas carol bro
get the [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
1940 yeah i don't think you're you're
not even a boomer if you were born in
1940. the baby boomers were the people
born from the gi is coming home like 92.
60 right
50. she's not she's older than me is it
greatest generation is called
um
maybe
yeah i guess yeah
did anyone find that clip i saw it on
twitter so here it is thank you again
guys look at this [ __ ] these this is our
leaders
as protests can be heard in the back
chanting outside of scotus house
democrats sing god bless america
watch this
these are the democrats these are brave
representatives
what a joke let's hear him out let's
hear it
olivia listen listen closely it's gonna
make you feel better let's see what they
got to say
yeah it's so calming the falsetto
shut the [ __ ] up
you're not even in tune
go [ __ ] do go
go
get on the phone
rally some people you got no energy
how are people born in 1940 supposed to
lead protests
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] in bed by 4 p.m
they can't even march bro she can't
barely walk
yeah [ __ ] you
i don't want a corpse leading my country
we can barely we can literally barely
rely on old people to drive properly
yeah
yes
1940
yeah abroad it's gotta get the image
imagine vibe yeah totally maybe that's
what we're missing
by the way nancy pelosi made 17 million
dollars in 2020.
oh that's weird is that salary or
is that uh no that's people that's from
stocks oh
yeah oh interesting
got on that gme boom
yes she probably got in early on that
yeah
no she's a big uh
she's a big uh a luna coin
investor she got out she got up just in
time yeah she avoided the rug pull
you know and the democrats are such
spineless
[ __ ] institutional
status quo monsters um people like aoc
are outcasts and whenever progressive
candidates run to actually have a chance
of winning and making change that
absolutely represents the will of the
younger people in this country they
[ __ ] run against them and
[ __ ] force birth freaks in texas yeah
honestly the conservative the
republicans have always been demons but
it's really the democrats that have
betrayed
us by doing nothing and being toothless
we have joe biden a democrat we have all
branches of government
i mean there's nothing to do this is the
supreme court but god these [ __ ]
people are spineless worthless
joe biden came and ride a bike man how
old is that [ __ ]
i bet you if you saw joe biden at a
family function he barely could hold a
coherent he'd be he'd just start
rambling i was gonna put him in that
he would start rambling and you would
slowly walk out of the room he probably
wouldn't even notice
he's old
you go crying to him grandpa that i have
to i'm pregnant and they won't let me
have abortion that that that that and
i'd be like let me let me tell you about
this poem your legs this poem that i
have for you yeah this
this poem might make you feel better
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
and i got the hairy legs and the kids
are jumping on my lap cozy economy
if you got into a conversation
uh
with joe biden i think he knew how that
would go
me yeah
shut up fat
no more than most people
that's why i'm running and you want to
check my shape on let's do push-ups
together man
[Applause]
it might have been before this i think
this clip might have edited no i think
it's coming
someone has said my son has done
anything wrong and i did not on any
occasion and no one has ever said it not
anything
you were doing anything wrong you said i
set up my son to work he said shut up
then what did you say come on
oh that's a good sound good job oh we
have get your word straight get your
word straight jack
oh there it is look fat here's the deal
look fat delete
i'll it your word straight jack
sagan oh yeah this this is actually so
accurate brett kavanaugh would totally
say this goodbye to your abortion [ __ ]
and that's exactly who brett kavanaugh
is we drank beer we drank beer we [ __ ]
the [ __ ] with friends of course i had
a girlfriend we got an abortion do you
like beer senator do you like beer
senator that's the ceo of uh gab by the
way he tweeted that so
say what gab the social media website
full of pedophiles and neo-nazis that's
the ceo of that company tweeting that
meme wait this isn't ironic
no no that's that's why i thought this
was a joke
but it is not supposed to be ironic oh
geez it's not it's not criticism of
brett kavanaugh
he's based
he thought this was uh ironic post yeah
the fact that i can't tell if he's
supposed to be like
super evil looking or not is
well the big cross in his handle is a
little bit of a tell ah very true
say goodbye to your abortions horse
jesus christ
here i'll send you his follow-up
right here that since and then there's
like their what you were saying how
their next step is to
take away gay rights
we're still in pride month yeah this guy
is actually just saying the truth at
least someone's speaking the truth the
christian takeover of our christian
country has begun
they're they're literally christian
fascists
they're
that's who they are these are the forces
that we're dealing with
bro i can't believe that post i can't
believe that was real i thought
i thought it was making fun of kavanaugh
for being a demon
no sir
he also
is anti-semite who wants to ban
circumcision circumcision
i thought they were down with that
no not this guy death to all jews
new free not free not
yes so 22 states basically have this
trigger law that they're going to make
it illegal immediately
and that's basically what's going to
happen
um
and that's that and that's that clarence
thomas man
i'm ready for him to die of a heart
attack
i'm just i'm fine wishing death on
people at this point okay wendy williams
all right why can't i wish death i'm not
doing anything they're low-key wishing
death on the women who can't properly
carry their yeah their pregnancies i'm
not now let me ask you what's wrong with
wishing death on someone not i don't
think dan's talking from a moral
standpoint i am not trying to
argue with you we have the merits of the
argument i'm trying to argue with you on
the let's not get banned from you yeah
oh okay okay okay
you think that's an offense to say i
wish death on someone
what did i yes
what did i do
i have no power over that i don't get to
decide who else and who dies i'm not god
i mean it is your birthday maybe
yeah you do have you gotta be careful
you have one wish to be how how many
years do you think this guy has the
birthday angels like seriously he's
probably this guy's
die this guy's not gonna let's just
listen to dan and then if you want we
can discuss it after the show okay yeah
how old is clarence thomas let's just
find out his age old enough rewind time
uh
no rewind somebody 74 he's 74 74. and
he's like a bad 74 you know what i mean
well
we'll see
we're gonna teach him how to say goodbye
teach them how to say goodbye one last
time
anybody yes pull up the lyrics to join
him
was that a hamilton thing again
george washington retiring after two
terms and going and enjoying his [ __ ]
retirement
wasn't he like in his 80s when that
happened no he was hella young when he
retired
at least on that stage that actor looked
young
or maybe chris jackson he was young when
he played oh [ __ ] he was only 67 when he
died so yeah yeah i did
dude
he retired
and
i don't know
i've got i've got conflicted
numbers amy you you you tell me when how
old he was when he retired
that's our second term of presidency
jordan washington oh george washington
here comes the general rule here comes
the general rule
ladies and gentlemen
the moment you've been waiting for
i think people need to start you know
what i'd be down people for the sing
this outside next we're out gone
oh man
outnumber
yeah go down to the part where he went
okay
wait this isn't one last time
i i just typed george washington this is
right-hand
it's not what i typed one last time is
is the
song we're looking for the riffs in it
are so beautiful i love that song
so inspiring nancy pelosi
have you heard that song nancy have you
seen that play
nancy pelosi has seen hamilton like 500
times i would guess he thinks he loves
it yeah
yeah yeah listen to that song it's great
anyway how old was george washington
when he retired oh he retired that when
he was president he was 57 uh when he
retired okay 50. he retired at 26 shout
out to saying 26 no no 65.
he served his second term as president
finally at age 65 washington left
philadelphia from mount vernon what 65
that's a nice i like diamond age that's
so nice
george washington that's a nice one huh
that is like the the age you're supposed
to retire right that's when you can get
like an arp card and stuff like that
yeah that's when you get those arb
discounts
so anyway our country i don't know what
to do
but
[Music]
uh i don't know
because they're a minority and i guess
we
i don't know
something's got to give though you know
what i mean
something's about to bust
in this country
wow you were fast because i was thinking
the same [ __ ] oh wow look at that
synergy
[Music]
yeah all we can do is hope that they
just die i mean that's really the that's
what that's the best outcome for us is
that all these old [ __ ] who are in
charge of all these important things in
the world just need to die because
they're all racist homophobic
transphobic old ass [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] who can barely send an email and
they're running our country they need to
die
of natural causes
yeah and vote i mean if we voted in
overwhelming numbers we would win every
election but young people don't give a
[ __ ]
they don't care
i understand the apathy but man
well we'll see what happens it come the
uh
you know we've got a huge election
coming up a midterm
and uh hopefully this [ __ ] energizes
people to go vote although it's like
what are we who are we gonna let joe
biden know that no he's not running
again well he's not running in the
midterms no but i mean you know
2024 you know
there's a lot of debate about that
whether he's going to run again and
people are like oh well he's too old
he'll obviously somebody else will run
or whatever have we not learned anything
the stupidest possible choice is the one
that we're going to make joe biden's
running again in 2024 a hundred percent
so how old so how old will he be 2024
his [ __ ] cryptkeeper age i don't know
he dude come on man
uh let's see i mean he's 79 now so it'll
be 81 uh ish he's like a bad 81 i mean
he's healthy like i've seen 80 year olds
who are pretty spry but i feel like he's
he's his mind is a little bit
deteriorated a little bit yeah
like he's not a good in a 79 you know
what i mean
he's a bad side brian just not president
fine yeah
it's fine as a grandpa yeah
grandpa joe with the hairy legs
and it get hot i got a lot of i got
hairy legs
that'd be fine as a grandpa
in truth we just we need good fierce
brave
hard-hitting leadership the liberals the
democrats whatever we need leadership
and we don't have it i feel like it's
coming up in the world i feel like the
sort of
the newer wave of millennial politicians
are definitely much further left than
their predecessors
but you know a lot of them are too young
to qualify and
uh there just seems to be this gap um
you know in
name brand
recognizable uh democratic politicians i
mean who who is there that's uh
prominent in their 40s or 50s to run
pete but a judge yeah that's steam kind
of hit [ __ ] him
uh he does look like trump ruined his
life when he said he looks like um
the dude from mad magazine
i know what i'm talking about newman
yeah he did call him
i think we've probably talked about it
but uh
let me show you i like i'm more partial
to the rat memes
the buddha judge rap memes
well anyway let's move on past this [ __ ]
we have fun stuff to talk about yeah and
we have um some ads that we are far far
over for so before that okay all right
let's just think well we have one ad let
me think and i have a whole album of all
these memes for me at howie's podcast
sitting extremely comfortably
on the couch you guys were kind enough
to
make a whole bunch of those
so let's thank our sponsor today hello
fresh
you know what's not going to be aborted
your hellofresh membership
does that kill the music
take off the graphic off the screen real
quick ian
hey aunt or ethan uh why don't we do our
ads okay today
for the first time
episode
sponsored by hello fresh
hello fresh we love them
hello fresh is the farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
boom
look at those delicious meals all
prepared
by poopa troopers
wow
what gorgeous oh gorgeous it is gorgeous
good boy
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable and that's why
it's america's number one meal kit and
also the number one meal kit of fupa
troopers oh what's inside that
uh not thumbtack that's a fine looking
burrito that's beautiful
on the one and only burrito
to rule all burritos
going away this summer update your
delivery address and enjoy hella fresh
at your vacation destination
plans are flexible so they work with
your changing schedule it's foolproof
step-by-step recipes
make a joyful cooking experience in a
stress-free summer plus hello fresh cuts
back on the time spent in the kitchen
with meals ready and around 30 minutes i
love hello fresh you know
it's fun it's easy you can't really mess
it up if you're a pro or an amateur chef
there's something to learn and enjoy
and the food is always delicious it's
always nutritious you don't even have to
think about it cooper troopers love
hello fresh
yup yup and it gets even better guys go
to hellofresh.comafterdark16
and use the code after dark 16 for up to
16 free meals and three free gifts
well that's hellofresh.com slash after
dark 16 america's number one meal
thank you what a read want to read
no mulligans flawless flawless first
time
that's actually smart that could make a
difference
i don't even know what you're referring
to yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right let's look at
the album
so i was on howie's podcast by the way
how we doing on how's the views on that
because it was kind of funny how
i guess i should talk about that we had
like it's all good with me and how we
and the sun we've worked it out he sent
me a d a nice dm good it's all good
howie or the sun the sun the sun really
yeah yeah okay how he texted me too and
said nice stuff
it's all good
i'm glad to hear it there's peace
between the family now ethan before you
get a little
too into this
we we have something for you here
in a second
is it howie mandel not how we move
he's about to pop out from behind
curtain
okay
[Music]
40 i'm not 40 what the [ __ ]
i'm not 40.
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so does this count as three uh thumbnail
pictures we're gonna have to send that
to led
yeah i'm not 40 for the record i'm 37
guys so you're looking we get some new
candles let me tell you yeah
really do you need some new candles here
guys yeah
did you make a wish this is the big one
big 4-0
make
yeah i wish for clarence thomas to die
okay
all right
all right
it's just a wish
it's just a wish of natural causes hey
um did you notice the
i didn't actually wish that by the way
how cool is the thumbnail cake
i love it no it's genius we need to send
this to phillyd so billy's aware philly
is aware unfortunately he we tried to
get him to come today
fortunately he is on vacation out of the
country he wouldn't even come he didn't
cancel his vacation for me
he said he would he said it was a
hilarious idea he wished
here but he is in
uh he fled the country he knew the
supreme court decisions were coming down
and he's like i'm out he's tropical
filler but i'm pretty sure that it's a
sanctioned thumbnail i think this counts
as three officially sanctioned yeah we
had his blessing that's nice well i if
he was here he would have showed up with
some hassan cake or some [ __ ]
i'm not 40 guys
i'm turning 36. next year for your 30 or
your 45th
you're a good
old man
i am old man [ __ ]
i'm not 40 yet okay so come on now we
have another surprise should we do we
want to hold off on that do we want to
do it i guess just keep it coming if
well the other one uh requires um us to
actually leave the set and um you saw it
on the way in you guys want to bring it
and i'll do look at some memes while you
set it up oh i go too no you have to you
know what it is it's not mobile you know
about this
maybe some knowledge
it's someone hanging did you guys hang
someone's dead okay let's go do it okay
here do we have that camera ready
[Music]
i am there's a birthday surprise i don't
know what it is
are you guys ready for me
[Music]
you any birthday plans anything
you got to go to someone's wedding which
is annoying
on his birthday on my [ __ ] birthday
and i'm so
sick of people inviting me to do [ __ ]
this whole month has been ruined with
people inviting me to do [ __ ]
all right i'm coming
[Music]
lina
okay
have you have they seen it we've got an
ikea tarp
and um you just take it off
i just see the tow truck lives matter
flag on the bottom there
sam made this
what the [ __ ] it's an oliver tree dog so
are we gonna burn it
oh you're gonna do it with a baseball
bat yes dude is there something inside
of it oh you'll find out yes this is
[ __ ] awesome all right so here hold
on a second now
did sam make that she sure did sam
so oh okay all right everyone back
really far up yeah ela get away from me
please
so this is oliver tree he's hanging by
noose he's been pumped to death
no news he's just he's just kind of
scared
uh it's just the strapper is that oh
okay i thought it was in this no no no
no all right here we go
everyone really get far away from me
okay
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
order or
[Music]
bit like this
other way to your right yeah yeah a
little more leverage there you go
is this good yeah
oh my god his leg just came flying off
all right let's get started
[Applause]
your favorite candy
almond joy we know you love all my
[Applause]
yours boys okay and wait i think i hate
those
a gift card
to sharkies ten dollars
to sharky oh you guys really haven't
forgotten the bad birthday presents i
got you guys
we did it thank you guys ten dollars the
sharkies let's go
and enjoy guys let's freaking go this is
incredible thank you
[Music]
oh okay okay all right all right
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well done well done my friend
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah
what thoughtful presents
do i have the best crew or what that's
right let me ask you this
who paid for the ten dollar sharky card
or put it on your credit card exactly
i i actually bought it wait you paid for
it i felt wrong to buy to
yeah
that's awesome
thank you ian that's so nice of you now
the uh the almond joys
we went back and looked at the tearless
the candy and that
unanimous we all put it at the bottom
it really is the worst candy isn't it
ask abe
you like them
you're muted
yes i put them in the freezer and then i
eat them i like them my grammy used to
do it i saw it they're just weird bro
there's a lot of almond joy defenders in
the chat too that's something yeah i
think one day i'll give it a second
chance
that can't be that day today is not that
camera dan has like a weird zoom
function when i was zooming in on you it
would zoom out on its own so it was
going in and out a certain point so i
apologize if that was jarring for anyone
in the audience ma'am
that looked amazing sam
she um she's getting a root canal yeah
the stamina
she's getting a root canal right now
she did an amazing job on that oliver
tree um
uh pinata
he was like just like i wonder if i'll
be able to
resuscitate the pinata afterwards kind
of save it i'm like
oh no he's gonna go off listen when you
hang oliver tree in front of me you
better
damn count i'm gonna destroy that thing
all right
thank you guys for heartwarming
display
literally heartwarming my heart is
beating
i'm beating that thing
too hot a little too warming
so anyway yeah uh we did howie's podcast
and um
we talked about it a lot on the last
episode
but
it was fun
and um
the angle was kind of insane though
it was dragging me up i was listening
and i felt like maybe it was like an
hour you guys still just dissecting the
shot
but it was that it was that wild
it was so here i'm at denny's this
actually looks legit man
which i've never been to denny's for the
record there's just like also something
about your hand on the hip like in a
fist
i'm pretty sure they shrunk my hand by
the way
are you sure
[Laughter]
no this is not funny
man i love their underwear though
they're so tidy whitey like who's str
that's that
the original image is a hanes commercial
actually
hell no it's not comfortable no it's not
that's not i lied
really [ __ ] in there so i guess i'm
ready
um here i am
enjoying the sun for my birthday
that looks pretty good
so legit
here i am
with tony hawk 1985
shredding up the half pipe
the half bowl
[ __ ] sick tony got a little higher
than me but you know i did good
i was hitting uh
in that grind a cobra kai
wow
spoiler alert
uh this is
this is a different one this is me on
top of the space needle and this is
drake's cover album right yeah
yeah
that's kind of fire that's how small i
looked in a studio though it was legit
shout out halle it's the cn tower by the
way not the space needle is that where's
that
believe this is in seattle uh the cn
tower is in toronto yeah okay
the album is called views from the six
as soon as i saw the shot though
i was thinking to myself this shot is
not okay
the minute i put it on i was like i look
this is horrible so unflattering
to the guest
[Laughter]
um
yo you were on comedy bang bang
apparently i was that's crazy i was just
sitting on the couch
that's awesome i love that show
here i am
on howie's head
oh my god
what kind of disrespectful you know he
doesn't like to be touched yeah he's
gonna have he's gonna react to this just
seeing me on his head in a
image
we've got um wow there's a lot of these
just crushing the skateboard again [ __ ]
yeah
and there you have it
so shout out howie mandel
the howie podcast
those were all so good
you got me uh sweating
are you worried about uh job security uh
oh they're all so good dude no one could
ever take your job come on pull up that
james charles
sunglass peak again that's job security
right there that was epic oh do you like
that one
oh no
what is going on with this
oh
we have a new james charles sound boat
unfortunately
actually i was listening to that part i
loved it
can you believe that video he put out no
i no i can't believe it and i was like i
was just listening and agreeing with you
guys how psycho it is
yeah did you see it so obvious the
cameron made yeah awesome right
it's so good genius i'm surprised you
love that that one why i don't know it
just seems so simple
well it's a great idea
beauty and simplicity yeah funny that's
why i like it thank you thank you
i can't believe that video and i don't
know what to say
it's just insanity he's [ __ ] up
so obvious what he's trying to do yeah
it's he's so demented but actually it
made me think of our boy um pnp
now he's in competition with another
tick tock lawyer who got off like
someone on three murders you remember
that who's pnp he's the lawyer our
lawyer
let's go guy well he needed to step it
up all right after seeing uh
the other attorney we were talking about
and so he stepped it up
this wonderful client of his was alleged
of violence on a minor
oh
let's go and by the way i notice how
during this video they don't even deny
it he's like it didn't happen exactly as
as they alleged
i mean which means you skew it you you
did it well i don't think so to be fair
i think there's
let's watch it listen to how he says it
all right we're right outside of santa
clarita courthouse
uh where we just got an amazing deal on
a case
my amazing client here was charged with
committing an act of violence towards a
minor
while we
disagree with that and we feel like it
didn't happen the way that it was
alleged
we got an amazing deal where after just
a little bit of community service case
will be dismissed how do you feel
i feel amazing man you guys did a
wonderful job man i appreciate you guys
going to bat for me and let the facts
show that you know i didn't do what they
alleged i did so i appreciate it thank
you save my life
oh thank you let's go let's go
all right we're right outside
he actually touched him there
but he's always thank you he's always
sure to wrap it up with the catchphrase
but the top comment is like i said the
top comment is you don't seem as
confident on this one and he responds he
responded low
let's go
i don't know the other the next comment
is nah he got the oj simpson gloves on
yeah and david david responded lol you
have great attention to detail like he's
not even
yeah crazy
didn't you think it was kind of small
yeah
bro what the [ __ ] you planning to go do
a murder after this
who just wears leather gloves except o.j
god damn it i was thinking to myself as
we were watching like i swear to [ __ ]
god i'm sorry
i was thinking like is it a covey thing
is like germs i don't know but that
glove was throwing me off too
but don't you think that he uh pnp was
like it didn't happen exactly as they
allege it's like something happened yeah
because normally doesn't he go my client
is innocent yeah yeah okay
yeah
his heart was not
in that let's go no
we knew he [ __ ] up it was a shallow
you know
my great client was alleged of starting
world war iv
and committing heinous war crimes happy
to announce we got all charges dropped
let's go
just reading calls
yeah and then he said this one comment
they just go we disagreed with that
they alleged that he committed violence
on a minor we disagreed with that
and david just laughs he doesn't even be
like yeah he
he's like yeah my clients are nuts
there you have it guys p and p he's
still out there fighting the good fight
here's the news let's go
did we see this one
the tick tock yeah
why is it showing it as most recent
this one is today we're right outside of
court in downey with my amazing client
here now he was charged with a dui
causing injury and a hit and run causing
injury and these are a lot more serious
than the typical dui and hit and run
charges because they at least carry a
one year license suspension requirement
if he's convicted so he wasn't going to
be able to drive for an entire year if
he was convicted of that it was alleged
that he was at a party and he left the
party to go get more alcohol and that on
his way back from getting alcohol he
crashed into
six other cars
and
ran away and came back to the party
that's what happened
he came out
and
it's alleged that he admitted to him
drank before he left the house and he
admitted that he was the driver
at the end by the way i love how long
this is we're only halfway through he's
like yo can we shoot a video real fast
and then he's like look at all these
crimes this homie did
before the dude even knew what was
happening
the result that we're very happy about
uh what happened to the dui causing
injury and the hit and run causing
injury charges they take it away i was
happy as
as amazing man good lawyer we have
dismissed right yeah he is the best
and he's just taking a reckless driving
all right no dui not even a normal dui
just reckless driving yeah he's the best
and
and run
no injury hitting a run causing property
damage you feeling good so happy i gotta
go celebrate
let's go
yeah i love that he's gonna go celebrate
nobody's he's gonna drive drunk and hit
some more
is the best nobody doesn't like him i
mean let's be real
my my client jeffrey dahmer here was
accused of
kidnapping and uh r wording 25 young men
they found it's alleged they found
skeleton remains in his backyard and
it's alleged that he admitted
that it's a fact it's alleged that he
did a taped interview with police where
he admitted to all the crimes
even ones they didn't know about
the exact location of bodies
well i'm happy to announce that my good
client jeffrey dahmer here we got off
with a uh
with a uh
uh a
reckless reckless driving i don't know
all right let's move on let's let's do
let's you know what i'm really excited
about um
this jimmy lee segment we've prepared
let's do it so is he standing by zach is
he ready to go he is in the waiting room
okay so here's what let me set this up
guys you guys are going to love this
we had the idea
to
do a loyalty test on jimmy
and i don't even know if jimmy knows
about this loyalty test yet does he no
he's finding about out about it now yeah
so he had this idea
first the first part of our
uh experiment on jimmy
was to call him
the thing that started all this okay is
that he was leaving comments
under keemstar's tweets
so this is what gave us the idea
to goof with him a little bit
where's that section do we have the
tweets that he was leaving keemstar
they're in the edit that we made
so yeah play play it up to
the the uh first part where we
go ahead just play it you guys will see
what what's going on here all right so
we're doing a loyalty test with uh jimmy
lee we see he's been in uh keemstar's
replies we're gonna we're gonna test to
see if the jersey outlaw really is a
true foot soldier and uh dedicated
you gotta pause it on the tweet
all right so we're doing a loyalty test
with uh jimmy lee we see he's been in uh
jimmy was responding to keemstar
like he just said we know that it's the
jersey outlet it's nonsense i don't know
what he's getting at i'm not sure but
we're like okay jimmy's trying to flirt
with keemstar
so we called him and we said jimmy just
so you know
keemstar is a bad dude and he hates
ethan so avoid him that was the first
step so that he couldn't deny that he
knew king star was enemy of the show
so with that being said let's watch the
first part here
stars replies we're gonna we're gonna
test to see if the jersey outlaw really
is a true foot soldier and uh dedicated
to the show
i love the pictures but i gotta kind of
talk to you something about private is
there any way you can get off speaker so
we we see that you've been
uh posting in keemstar's replies on
twitter is that you
no
maybe it's basic
mason is a keemstar what what is the
response saying
he posted something of amber heard lmfao
and jimmy lee the jersey outlaw and
responded we know that it's the jersey
outlaw
was that you
i don't know if i did that or that
doesn't sound like they may have been
mason what else is up there well that's
what we've seen but anyways
don't do it no no just just i just
keemstar is a bad guy he hates ethan we
know that when we did the second shoot
you know that right right he's just a
bad dude so i gotta tell mason don't
even respond on his thing okay yeah just
just no keemstar nothing oh you got it i
got you yeah you called me i don't think
i did it because i don't do my twitter
right that's not your twitter account
honestly i'm always honest with you zach
all right
we'd appreciate that well for what you
do for me please all right thank you
jimmy appreciate it i love you buddy
tell ethan's story i'll take care of it
right away all right thanks jimmy okay i
love you so he claims that it wasn't him
that's the first part by the way the
guys just brought me pizza
you guys all got pizza too right yeah
okay
did you guys are you guys being forced
to eat my flavor
i think there's some other ones no
there's some other ones yeah
for people that are sane
your flavor i didn't know they got pizza
i was like oh damn turn up this slices
are so fat i'm ready to party
so at the the
the strategy there
was to give him no out
to say oh my god dude what
what the [ __ ] is this this is all for
you
hila do you want another another kind
no
i'm good is there any more
what other kind you got there okay
jesus
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's just showing me all the well you
guys eat and enjoy
oh i'll enjoy the pizza
you get yourself uh some uh kebab pizza
today guys get some pizza come on it's a
party toast
everyone please enjoy
come on
[Music]
so anyway
thank you for the pizza party everyone
it's such a treat what flavor you get
there
oh white sauce
yeah
even though i do like your your
layout i don't know what to call it it's
not flavor
what is my flavor
because my patented flavor
can i have some
i have to say so far jimmy is passing
the test already well he was his
reaction was very nice
well he denied that it was him yeah i
think it was him what do you think zach
oh without a doubt it was definitely he
works with a guy
his name is mason i believe yeah he's a
social media guy and then it's in the
video
immediately after this but
he texts me and he's like i think our
twitter got hacked
oh yeah yeah yeah so it was definitely
jimmy oh without a doubt okay yeah and i
don't know how he found keemstar got the
idea to write under his
i i believe it's this guy he's working
with
oh yeah that's why he found out about
keemstar because he got harassed
on the street biking right right
but he doesn't know what's going on
right so we said
he has no deniability now so the next
phase okay and our loyalty test
was to have olivia pretend
to be a producer from dramaalert
and offer keemstar the opportunity of a
lifetime
his own show
a huge pay
dramaalert loves keemstar
let's see let's see the next part please
ian i think we still need to roll the
dice with this one and i kind of believe
him i believe him i think he's innocent
here yeah okay yeah okay and i think
he'll pass the loyalty test i think he
will too yeah i think he will too olivia
is going to call as keem's assistant or
uh producer for drama alert we're gonna
we're gonna see what happens so here we
have olivia she is our actor today
jimmy ended up saying his twitter got
hacked so
hi um i'm looking to get in touch with
jimmy lee the jersey outlaw for a
business
inquiry yeah what's your name
my name is kat everdeen i'm an associate
producer at um a youtube show
entitled dramaalert and we were
wondering if you would possibly be
interested in co-hosting an episode or
two
yeah
okay great well we're huge fans we've
been uh
we've been following you online
it's called um drama alert where the
host that you would be with is named
keemstar he's a comedian on youtube
so i think that's ethan's enemy though
oh ethan h3
yeah we've heard about him
you know i'm very loyal thank you
they've really been good to me so i'm an
older guy i'm very loyal so well we're
not looking to step on any toes we just
we don't have
obviously compensate you for your time
it'll be 10k for the first episode if
that's if that works with you we could
obviously
we could negotiate something that works
for both of us what's your latest name
everdeen you're not coming up on the
internet do you not come up with your
drama well i'm fairly new i mean i
graduated
last month so oh should we get your
keemstar
with an email you want my email yes
please will you send me an email with
all the information and all that yes i
will do i will get right on that and
i'll se
thank you so much bye
you're going olivia he was sweet though
no that's not loyal oh there you go so
pretty interesting result
people are saying it's cruel it is it is
a little bit of a goof but
jimmy's a rich dennis he's not like
he jimmy's you jamie or jimmy
yeah jimmy he drives a rolls royce okay
don't worry about it he does yeah he's
got a colon he's got the same car i used
to have whoa he's a baller
what color
do you know what color it is he's got a
uh he's got a uh
a phantom it's black
yeah
so
but the guys this he was tweeting under
keemstar we're having a little fun don't
feel too bad for jimmy okay we're having
a little fun here no it's all fun it's
my birthday yeah so far you already
responded really well though so at first
he passed the test he straight up said
we're allies that's ethan's enemy but
once the subject of money was brought up
10k
per episode it turned into uh send me an
email i got to give it to olivia she was
a great actor
she did great things off the cuff
[Music]
and um she did a great job oh thank you
well zach fed me some great lines
well
your original um
debut olivia was asked keemstar's
girlfriend it's true oh my god the band
the band yeah the other band
came back
so what was the email we sent jimmy
um let me pull it up
is it in the video should we just play
the next part
there's a there's a picture of it in the
dark but don't show it yet
because it kind of gives something away
you got the email
the screenshot in the dock kind of gives
something away so i don't i don't want
to show that one so here's the email
i've got it right here
it'll be okay
so here what the frick
whenever i move it disappears hey you
see this scroll down disappears
can you just leave me alone
it's my birthday just work
let me try incognito
okay
weird
this is so this is the email we sent and
this is kathleen everdeen i'm associate
producer drum alert
your client jimmy lee
and i spoke on the phone
about him hosting with daniel keane
this is a project that keemstar is very
interested in pursuing compensation is
ten thousand dollars per episode
kim is willing to offer jimmy
20 000 for the first episode
based on the response from our audience
and how the team feels about the show we
can discuss and drop the contract
please let me know so how did jimmy
respond to this
he did not he didn't respond to the
emails
he texted the number he had for me from
his own phone and he said
have keem called jimmy
that's what he was hung up on is keem
calling him yeah so i wonder if we could
have
you gotta you gotta finish the video
yeah we have a few more phone calls yeah
did you get someone to sound like keem
to call him no we didn't get that far
well let's play it go ahead let's watch
the next part zach
that's not loyal right there dude
it was no no
hello this is kate
this is cat yes
do you know that you were on the hunger
games we need to know if that's you
no that is jennifer lawrence
what's the next step
well i'm putting together an email right
now i just want to make sure that that
you are interested before i before i do
all of this well um i don't want to
jeopardize a relationship with h3hd i've
been very loyal to them so if there's
anything that would do that i don't want
to do it i'm going to be honest with you
but if it's something that doesn't
jeopardize that okay i'm going to do
anything to jeopardize because i know
ethan and keemstar do not like each
other zach told me that
yes
i'm an old school and a good honest guy
so i have the cappy up front i don't
want mine money or no money right we're
we're not looking for you necessarily to
be combative toward ethan that's that's
all keem
um we're just interested in the dynamics
that you two would have
right and that's fine but here here's
what you understand i'm older okay i'm
in my 50s
and i
have a regular business i would never do
nothing to hurt them and i wouldn't want
to be on a podcast with keemstar i don't
want to do anything come back towards
anything zach none of them because
they're like my second family they
brought me in and they lost and that's
how i'm very old school no but that that
that's very we want to be your third
girl
they love me and i love them and we're
really tight and sad
that i can do it but as long as that's
the promises
they've told me that too yes i i will
definitely pass that along
okay
that's good
thank you thank you
thank you that sounds great have it have
a good day
thank you all right bye
he's so nice you guys i can't do it so
there it is jimmy lee
i i'll be honest from the top i think we
all were unanimously like oh he's gonna
he's gonna fail this spectacular really
i think the opposite really because we
we figured he was so
he wanted this opportunity
the money
but he keeps saying he he doesn't want
anything to do with uh going against you
very impressive uh the loyalty test has
been absolutely slammed
by jimily people are calling him is
there more
is that the whole
yes so that's all we got so there it is
jimmy actually
passed with flying colors mm-hmm family
he's a he's a true one yeah pretty sweet
what's that didn't he text you the email
yeah yeah he i i sent that to cam yeah
that's the picture in the dog oh okay so
he uh he actually ended up texting me
a print out
and then he took a picture on his phone
of the of the email that's awesome
which is in the dump damn it doesn't
work
here uh i can see if it opens on my i
just got to do incognito
so this is
so he sent you the email he was actually
even giving us all the intel he sent us
the email a picture of the printed email
um
and below that saying um zach look at
this they reached out to me keemstar i
told them period i'm loyal to the h3 and
damn jimmy lee
oh the goat man he's the goat
wait what damn i just saying that
message look zach look at this they
reached out to me keemstar i told them
i'm loyal to age three and not
interested cause i'm with ethan and you
guys
what a guy he's loyal man you gotta give
that to him jimmy is a loyal lawyer
let's bring him on the phone he's he's
standing by right he was for the last
like 20 minutes he just hung up i swear
to god just now all right i'm texting
him
tell him to tell him to log back in
there you go though he's really been
sitting there for
this entire time maybe he got upset he
was he was gypped
he's big time on us
he's calling keem someone say he may be
the jersey outlaw but he's our jersey
outlaw that's right right can you rip
this
you want me to rip this off yeah
the the tag keep like
yeah there you go
thanks
well that was wholesome actually
you're not pretty good
very sweet
i wish we had more people to do it too
but i couldn't i wanted to do it to a
bunch of people but i really couldn't i
i was it would be too mean to do it to
gabe you know i couldn't boil yeah
um
i feel like jimmy was
i i feel like he's gonna be okay with
this and yeah he's gonna joke her
and he's like okay well he passed it
he's coming out looking better than ever
[ __ ] seriously man
i don't i don't think he could have
performed any better
in the way he handled it
i was trying to push him the other way i
wanted to see how outrageous he could
get towards kim's team
i wanted him to send a middle finger
back i just i just texted him he read uh
i just said hop back on click the link
we're ready for you
you read it so it didn't answer he
didn't answer
well if jimmy gets back on we'll we'll
take the call but there you have it
ever love jimmy lee oh there he is
he just popped in all right let's say hi
standby
hold it
jimmy
outlaw dan
did you take your viagra dan dan
are we all ready are we all ready happy
birthday to
you
who are these people he's in atlantic
city right now
are these just random people yeah
oh my god
happy birthday
to
you
[Music]
jimmy
johnny
jimmy flip your phone dude can you make
it big or is it because
jimmy can i ask you a couple questions
not until i fix my phone honey hold on
we've been waiting for you
i made me stand in front of hotel and
tell corny jokes for a half an hour is
that bad
gotta help this can you see me or no i
can see you jimmy right now where are
you right now i don't i don't see you oh
you don't julia what do i do
hold it hold it hold it hold it hold it
audio
[Laughter]
oh
to go back out and go back in
hold on jimmy jimmy can i just uh
oh i got you i got you i got it
jimmy can i say something to you
it's time i'm here so where are you
jimmy
we're at the hard rock casino
in atlantic city new jersey and there's
the hard rock guitar and here's julia
and who are your fans who okay
and these are all the other fans
there's a lot more than me okay okay
where did you find it
where did you find these people jimmy
joyah tell tell ethan how you felt wow
and what about the other guys
they're with julia they're with georgia
and i have dr greg the plastic surgeon
friend that's dr greg happy birthday
hey hey tell your doctor greg
why is he helping you out a little bit
more
for the day why aren't you helping me
with my
surgery
uh plastic surgery he says he's gonna
add a tail
well thank you thank the girl for us
that's really nice but jimmy you passed
the test you you you get the keys to the
chocolate factory what do you mean i pay
us the test
do you not were you not watching afraid
they asked you
where are you listening to this we're
out here doing jokes
no no we were out here doing jokes have
you heard anything about a loyalty test
jimmy that's so funny
are we talking about the thing that i
said zach yeah
dramaalert
[Music]
it was the thing that i said zach yeah
dramaalert
[Music]
it was us the whole time jimmy we were
testing you
julia they scared me
yeah they tested me
but i sent him the thing
so like tell you i'm going you fast you
passed the loyalty test jimmy
it's a birthday i couldn't ask for a
better birthday present than jimmy
delivering on the loyalty test fears for
all the hookers out here tonight all
right all right all right
okay hey hey hey ethan you know the cool
thing about hookers they got it they
sell it and they still got it think
about it right right right because it's
it's it's it's a
it's not like a commodity that gets used
up it's it's you could they can drop it
drape it droop it right a b
yeah maybe that's my father
don't make me do the camel joke don't
make me do the camel joke it's my
favorite one do the camel joke jimmy
come on it's my birthday do the camel
going
okay
i hope you find a parking place for your
camellia oh god hell yeah
can you please refer to me as maybe the
arab the way you refer to ethan the jew
i'm going with julia we're going in the
kitchen let's go
so i told jimmy to go find a quiet place
to do this
there's no quiet place
no
too loud for audio audio give him an
audio audio audio
well jimmy uh i just want to say thank
you for
passing the loyalty test you made me a
very happy birthday boy
well i love you and i told zach i sent
him the thing
i i didn't really know it was you i
thought mason thought it was a prank
and we didn't think it was you and we
thought it was somebody playing a game
and i said to mason we got to show zach
and then zach you you fooled me too
you're like what's this [ __ ] i gotta
show ethan but exactly you obviously
knew
of course i knew dude
but but jimmy let me ask you i'm gonna
were you ever tempted uh
did you ever think it was real and maybe
a good opportunity for you
no because you have been loyal to me and
you're one of the reasons i'm where i'm
at and if you ever thought i jeopardize
that for 20 000 when you know i have
money
i would never do it um and my wife who's
asian and rich she would never do it
either because we're about uh character
and loyalty and love and you've treated
me great and and the last couple of
times i've been on things have been
getting good so why in the f would i
jeopardize
you guys my friends i know you don't i
know you don't like them anyway i found
that out when that goofy kid was on the
street when i made fun of him remember
oh yeah what is it you said uh what was
it you said about your wife being asian
what did you mean by that
she's like the crazy rich asians from
the movie right julia
who is this julia wait
yeah
stop it jimmy that's not appropriate
stop stop stop stop i'm teasing yeah but
you're making her uncomfortable come on
she is uncomfortable you're sitting on a
bench put it put a pad there right right
they get worse hillary don't worry what
jimmy um is your wife come from money
uh yes
but i'm not how to say that well you did
alright just kill me so now
but that zach told me i can't talk about
my wife when the [ __ ] did i say that
all right jimmy you take care you got
fun in atlantic city okay go have a good
time thank you buddy not not not
wait a minute hold it hold it
one second
one two three
and many more
okay thank you buddy
all right jimmy lee the jersey out
jamie
thank you julia thank you thank you
peace and love have a good night love
you guys all right love hi hi jimmy
thank you jimmy
wow
wow what a god huh unbelievable
with flying colors yeah really good
shout out to julia good luck
that's pretty awesome that they found
each other he makes stuff that means i
mean he says stuff that make no sense to
me and like i i really have no idea what
is the meaning well he said worse you
know what kind of friends we are you
know what he's talking about right
i guess i guess it has benefited yeah
yeah
why did he say something about the bench
with a pillow he said put a rag down
what it's just you just gotta call it a
jimmy joke that's all it is it's just a
jimmy joke that she's dirty that she
[ __ ] her pants no cause you said you're
making her uncomfortable and then he
said oh you're just doing that oh like
be comfortable
very literally very literally yeah okay
so i asked him the the reason i asked
him to call in was we want you to wish
ethan a happy birthday
so
he's like okay okay but then can i do
jokes
he's like we want to go in the kitchen
again like last night it was great i'm
like jimmy we struck lightning in a
bottle with that
we just want you to sing happy birthday
to ethan this time okay but i'm in ac
okay cool find a quiet place and he just
wouldn't listen to me
there's no quiet place in jimmy's life
and we love that
all right
let's go we got a few more things i want
to talk about
um
what is this
oh wow
you trying to i thought you were trying
to tell me something
am i covered in sauce
so david dubrick is being sued by jeff
whittick there's a little piece of juicy
gossip that came out of this
during a paparazzi video
you can hear in the background her
partner saying
off camera i had a great talk with david
dobrik today
and camille responds good
how [ __ ] interesting is that i want
to see
yeah watch this it's super super
compelling
because i watched it at first i was like
what did i just see you got to listen to
what they say in the back
so who am i watching this is johnny
depp's attorney that david is hiring
well that's the assumption we're making
just listen to what they say here
that was indisputable you heard it
i had a great talk with david dobrik
so what do you make of that
is he really
do you think he's really hiring them to
defend against this jeff
that is why people are saying it yeah
the timing because it just happened
huh
that's very interesting it seems like
overkill i don't know
for the job didn't they already file the
lawsuit though so they would have
already talked a lot
does that make sense no he i have a
feeling david just found out about it at
the same time we all did
that's how it's always been for me i
always found out laughing but after at
[ __ ] the media and everyone else
yeah
this paparazzi video is from may
oh what the [ __ ] yeah jeff mentioned
around that time that he's going to take
legal action so david this is from may
people just now noticed it
exactly wow oh that's re-examining the
evidence
well do they specialize in defamation
what do these lawyers
specialize in or is
they were defending
no no they were they were the plaintiff
in a defamation case
which makes me think is david gearing up
to sue somebody for defamation
he might be counter-suicidal case or
do you think maybe the the doc
the casey dog um that's an interesting
theory
that's an interesting theory he might be
working to get prevent it from getting
distribution
that's a that's a really interesting
theory
because these guys seem like they're
litigators they're
they're they're prosecutors
and you know
clearly they want a huge defamation case
so
that's very interesting i i somehow feel
yeah that is overkill for defending
against jeff's
lawsuit
that's a good theory that is for the
documentary
let's see their specialty is
focuses on plaintiff side defamation
suits
that's their specialty grumpy
which means david's gearing up to sue
someone for defamation
how [ __ ] interesting is that why you
think he's gonna sue me
i i don't
well
human fecal matter
[Music]
with additional experience litigating
contract disputes
business related torts
and employment related claims
they can sue me i i don't think they are
but they're welcome to get in line
love being sued at this point
what love can we get to televised
classic oh we would need a jury trial
that's good content we could reenact it
that'd be such good livestream content
that would be kind of epic just to go to
jury trial
oh my god depositions are pretty funny
they're intense and insane it's like
your honor uh could you please explain
what is your problem with his laugh
yeah question to you oh that would be a
question i loved reading your first
deposition that was so good there has
ethan like can you explain what a like
is
can you define what is a meme
literally they but i don't know dude
well that's real interesting i think
he's more likely going to be
litigating against actually i think the
documentary is the best
explanation for that i mean but that
poses the biggest threat to him at this
moment
there was i mean they barely
said anything that was new i don't see
why what could be defamation about it it
was all like very
straightforward he might be saying that
they don't have
his uh permission or something or i
don't know
i mean it ha it happens a lot like when
people put out documentaries that are
critical of the participant they always
try to block it you know yeah
oh yeah did jeff text back no but the
lawsuit is out it's public now did you
have text back
no my best buddy never got back
come on on your birthday at that
disappointing
yeah i know
damn wow
well that's [ __ ] real interesting
isn't it
so it's either me
trisha
casey
or jeff
yeah
or cat
no
uh
well i mean is this insider yeah
business insider that's interesting
maybe because that's kind of what this
is interesting
before right like an article type thing
super similar but it seems pretty well
sourced
that article
um
well as you know um
a defamation lawsuit doesn't necessarily
need to make sense for somebody to try
and push for it and uh file it yeah of
course i think that just jeff makes the
most sense i mean jeff has been popping
off on his show about
uh david for a while
where my mind goes is specifically all
of the stuff about david having supposed
to have paid his legal fees and not and
like the specifics of that there i could
see
david maybe
having something that
he is accusing jeff of uh lying about
my problem with the jeff thing is that i
have i really think david just found out
about jeff's lawsuit at the same time we
did
but there's a possibility that that's
not the case well if they knew about it
that means that they were trying to
do some kind of settlement
talks
before he filed yeah
which is possible i guess and maybe they
just
their their settlement attempts went
sideways
very interesting i in my opinion to get
like those big ass
over-the-top lawyers would have to be
a huge would be like against a huge
media company like business insider or
casey neistat's production company
casey poses the biggest threat if that
gets to a mainstream platform i think
he's deathly afraid of that
i feel like there's no containing it
though at this point even if he's not
able to relate release it i feel like
somebody already has a copy somewhere
yeah but it's different it's like
mainstream consumption where everyone
can go watch it yeah yeah because i
think like what 99 of the people on
youtube who care about it probably
haven't even seen the documentary
right right um cameron just
just sent some very compelling evidence
that it that you might be right that it
might be about cat just not the cat that
we were thinking
that cat right because that's the cat
that really yeah ruined his life that
could be actually yeah i'm here live
that's not i'm not a cat it's definitely
the
the truck's fault
if there's anyone to blame
well i hope it's not me don't sue me
what the [ __ ] did i do
i don't think so
what did i do
i mean i don't think you did anything
wrong yeah that's all i needed to hear
yeah but i mean we have that's all i
needed to hear dozens and thousands of
hours
but the thing is
david is down pretty bad and i'm sure
those lawyers are like [ __ ] expensive
after that
yeah they're like 800 an hour type of
[ __ ] oh
i think more than that
man how much did johnny depp pay for
that lawsuit it must have been insane
millions for sure
dropped a
grumpy
real quick um jimmy just texted me he
said i can't believe that you guys did
that i'm gonna get
you he's going to silly donkeys after us
he's going to get us
i'm scared to know what jimmy's idea of
getting us is yep
wouldn't be crazy if he sued tricia
that'd be like the craziest turn of
events ever
that won't make any sense yeah but she's
straight up she says whatever she wants
but that doesn't affect her yeah but
there's no right i think trish i don't
think you could ever sue trisha for
defamation because yeah
nobody takes what she says seriously i
think if it's like you guys said if
there's any
motivation for him to sue it's to
prevent something from going mainstream
that's what i think yeah
damn i should ask casey if he's heard
from them mm-hmm
should i text him right now
yeah i yeah i really doubt it's
basically though
yeah yeah i could that would admit it to
him too more
but jeff is just
i don't know what's the point of suing
jeff that would be a pr disaster for him
i think it would be insider in that case
insider makes more sense to me than jeff
jeff doesn't make any sense it's just
it's f'ed up to sue him
at this yeah that would look so bad
okay ethan
yeah it would be it would look so bad
that'd be so bad yeah
jesus
or i just asked casey
i said yo is david suing you
was it insider who spread that like
alcohol story first
insider broke that whole story
the thing about the essay and the girl
and the alcohol
but it all seemed like
well i guess we'll see you know because
if that's it we're going to be mentioned
for sure right because we talked about
that quite a bit sure we'll be mentioned
i mean i'm let's go yeah i just i don't
i don't i just don't want to have to pay
any lawyers
i'm just thinking about the content
content great let's go yeah dude that's
like a whole year of content let's go
and we got the johnny depp lawyers i
mean turn up
let's go yeah
turn the [ __ ] up
let's go
let's go
should we take a pull who's david suing
i mean we're all just playing
speculation there's really who do you
think
david is suing so the options would be
jeff
insider
casey casey
or ethan
all right let's see what we say so
i'm voting for don't say who okay let me
think here let me think
[ __ ] it's a tough one but i'm thinking
this one thank you for keeping the poll
on it stila
yeah just so you understand this
election was a fraud
so stop the count so the
the votes are in thank you to 20 18
think he's suing me
the lowest one though
but it's pretty spread out insider leads
followed by jeff and then casey i think
it's casey i really do
you do yep it's more timely than the
insider article yeah isn't it a little
late for that and the betrayal the
aspect of betrayal that he's built up in
his mind yeah and he thought that this
he didn't realize it was a hit piece
when he participated in it 100 i think
it's got to be the casey thing it's got
to be unless he has some powerful allies
oh [ __ ] he texted me back like david
sorry
sorry go ahead lev
uh i have a fifth option you guys know
that he had this discovery thing the
like discovery show i wonder if
something weird could have happened
there with the discovery some drama
about that that we haven't even heard of
okay
that's
[Music]
the thing is he's got show biz lawyers
and [ __ ] probably that do all that sure
and if it was like a contract dispute or
something it wouldn't be a defamation
thing
right yeah just speculating
i'm texting with casey right now
thank you for everyone saying it's a
terrific poll good poll shiny pole dan
thank you so much
wow
so much love for the poll out there
folks as always
i love that nobody ever criticizes the
polls that i post
on this show
and um i love you all
frankly
well
[Applause]
casey has casey
says that
[Music]
he doesn't think so and he hasn't heard
anything about it so
all right fingers crossed for for his
sake yes
dude they're probably so pissed that
that got out though someone [ __ ] up
big time
yeah the guy he was kind of like flexing
i don't know he was screaming from a
crowd hey i just got on the phone with
david dobrik
he said we're good it was her the main
partner what a
goon it did
weird
uh
yeah so
he casey suggested that it might be jeff
so there you go
well [ __ ] i do think that makes the most
sense well david is pretty dumb i mean
like perception stuff these days so but
suing jeff will make him look so demonic
i saw that um
the fact that jeff is suing him has been
picked up all over the news yeah no it's
a big one
so
that's gonna be real interesting to
follow but there you have it guys they
had a good meeting with david dobrik
juicy gossip
right here listen closely
dumbass what an idiot he clearly knew
the [ __ ] paparazzo was there right
yeah and he like shouted it like i can't
care anyone else except his dumbass
voice i had a great combo with david
so that's so interesting that people dug
this up
is david dobrik a common name could
could it be a second david dobrik no
oh yes my uncle uh
david steen dober okay i'm exploring all
the options here okay sure i appreciate
it no that's not an option
um here
there's one other thing i wanted to do
today
before we signed out
which was
oh yeah the board ape yacht club thing
so
this actually is a real interesting
developing story we talked about it
on wednesday
there was a big video that came out from
a youtuber called uh
was ilium phillian
and
he presents the research of this guy
um
what's the name of that artist writer
rips is his name yeah so this artist has
put together
an in very exhaustive
analysis that's basically accusing them
of being nazis
and it's it's pretty incredible we went
over it and i think all of us were
fairly convinced by the end of it that
there's definitely something going on
here now where this story gets
interesting is
last night i got a text
from a friend of mine
who's connected to showbiz
and said this there's this dude
who's a big time hollywood uh manager
who manages
the board eight yacht club
and he wants to talk to you he's in the
video like he's one of the people that
uh philly and goes over when talking
about he does oh show me that part yeah
one second okay because i know this
guy's not a nazi like i can definitively
say that he's he's israeli american
and he's he's like
he's just you know a big a hollywood big
time guy
um
that's very interesting so let me see
what he said about him because
well anyway he
eventually we got on the phone
and um he was trying to convince me uh
apparently that
it's all a big farce
it's all first and um this is all a
farce
i'll tell you kind of what he said a lot
of the stuff that they say
and people who are defending this saying
it's all a farce that they're not nazis
is stuff that that was said in the video
that he set up and said so there there's
really nothing new
to defend them but i'll tell you did you
find the part are you looking no i'm
scrubbing through right now trying to
find it and you already talked about
that video on the show yeah i'm talking
about it on wednesday exhaustively it's
super interesting
so one of the main things that he said
on the on when i was talking to him
because their their logo this is the
board apes uh yacht club
is an exact
like carbon copy
of this nazi emblem the
waffen
toten cough whatever
and what he said in defense of this is
this is just a normal emblem like if you
search up any motorcycle club
they have similar looking emblems
and so my way of determining if that was
true or not is we did a research i said
can you guys find
any emblem
that looks like this
that isn't like nazi adjacent
and you you said you looked for a
straight 30 minutes dan and what was the
result of your search um i'm so
this was just googling around i can't
say that this is comprehensive and there
are a lot of motorcycle clubs out there
but
after
scrolling through tons of google image
results and going to a few websites that
have like databases of
biker patches and all that kind of stuff
i grabbed all the ones that popped up to
me that i feel i'll have an obvious um
relation and then kind of work backwards
from there to look into the group uh the
motorcycle club to see
um what they're all about
and these were the ones that i was able
to come up with i think this one is
fairly self-explanatory it's a big red
swastika it's it's yeah uh here's
another one this is the gypsy joker um
they are a west coast outlaw motorcycle
club with neo-nazi ties
and here is one other one called the
blood and honor social club um blood and
honor i think kind of indicates to you
what they're all about that's uh you
know
socially so i'm saying
[Music]
so um
yeah and uh
you know there's a lot that like vaguely
look like it but you know the ones that
are specifically a skull looking to the
left with like kind of a circular
text around it um that really resemble
that original one um
yeah they are they're all like aryan
nation dude so look at this one like
this one's like sons of anarchy i don't
know if they're i don't think they're
anything
but you see you got the black thing you
got the text on the bottom and the top
and skull
but it's very specific their logo
um how it has this specific layout of
like here
here
stuff here stuff here you don't see that
and then also the weird thing because 18
is super important to white nationalists
because it's like
it's his uh it's alphanumeric it
the number one
a adolf hitler first letter of the
outfit
number eight is h yeah they love that
[ __ ] it's corny as [ __ ] but you see them
with eight they like lots of like little
codes so what's it about
they have 18 teeth
and this one has 18 teeth and i even and
i even went by the way that's weird to
google and i was like counting the teeth
and none of them had 18 teeth they had
like 12
[ __ ] like that 18
that's very weird like
so this one has 18 4 6 8 10 12
14 16 18. yup
2 4 6 8 twelve
fourteen sixteen eighteen wait does that
one have twenty one two three four five
it looks like that one eight nine no it
has it is eighteen
now we should point out the other point
that he made to you about that logo
which which does seem to have some
validity to it is that um you know in
their comparison of trying to
uh
you know
point out the similarities between those
two logos he specifically points out the
kind of jagged edge around it
um as a point
of comparison the
original
nazi emblem doesn't have a jagged edge
um and so that was kind of that that
point was undercut yeah i don't know why
they needed to even include that because
the evidence is like
super compelling without it
yeah but the jagged edge thing isn't a
real thing like you you really can't
really find this with the jagged edges
right uh uh yeah yeah
but like
that aside
it's it's so hard
to
say that this isn't a direct nod i i
just i don't know how you can do it the
18
is very specific like from a designer
point of view i can understand like
maybe being inspired by the aesthetic
and not knowing what it means maybe
although you do your research even if
you didn't know well these guys are not
they're 4chan users for sure
so they know all this [ __ ] yeah exactly
so there's no way they didn't know the
meaning but like go to go look at skull
and crossbone
or whatever and count the teeth there
you know what i mean like 18 like here
let's see one two three four five six
seven eight oh that's that's actually
sixteen sixteen
one you know what i'm saying i i was
reading i was
looking on the emblems motorcycle
uh
design patch
tons of skulls
not seeing any skulls and there were
other things about tons of other things
i might get to other stuff
but yeah let's see let's see one uh
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven so that one's not
eighteen
i'm just saying you guys can go look and
count it yourself it's it's so but then
okay so that's one aspect
now they just put out a statement the
board ape yacht club
guys someone said i lost weight it looks
like i've lost weight thank you ashley
for noticing that
i think the web is actually doing a good
thing nice oh nice
have you noticed i lost weight are you
avoiding telling me
i to be honest with you think you did a
little
but i'm afraid of saying anything
because i don't want to jinx it i'm very
very less i'm not like before i started
the wellbutrin i had this
insatiable
[ __ ] ever-present hunger that was
just
i could i couldn't overcome it i mean it
was it was driving me crazy and i would
lay in bed every night like so [ __ ]
depressed that i
couldn't control my eating but now
i feel i don't feel that anymore
i'm glad you're finally doing this when
i had two slices of pizza or maybe three
and i was like full i couldn't eat
anymore that's good that is definitely a
change
right no for sure
whole tray yeah exactly when you're when
you would say in the beginning you're
not even hungry or something right
i was like yeah i i was surprised i was
like i'm full right now
that's awesome that's great i'm very
good at it here
thank you guys
so going back to the um
to the board 8 yap club so
they put out a statement this morning
um
which they've never done before
do you have a link to that guys yeah
it's in there oh here it is thank you
and these guys are anonymous they're
very secretive and they have never put
out a statement and here today
uh they're not anonymous or well welcome
they're very private let's say i don't
think that they've never addressed this
rumor right and what the guy was talking
to said this was a direct
response to our podcast on wednesday
okay one of them is a fan
and they say in here
that they saw it on a podcast
of someone they respect
and so they felt that they could no
longer
not say anything about it
let me try to find that and so
first let me ask a simple question now
that they've heard the feedback are they
changing it
it doesn't seem that it doesn't seem so
and that is something i think that's a
very simple telling
answer because i if i if i ran into this
issue as a designer right and let's say
i i was just
simply inspired by the aesthetic and i
didn't know what it was finding out what
the meaning is i would immediately
change it
yeah um maybe there are planning on
doing that but yeah that's a little
baffling to me too i mean this was
pointed out to them the original website
that this video
is based on the one that he pulled up
here i believe was published like in
january maybe february of this year so i
mean we're talking like six months
they've been aware of these conspiracy
theories
it kind of just took off when this dude
made a video about it
so they know about it definitely
definitely here's what they said about
we've not responded in further detail to
these allegations because frankly they
are insanely far-fetched that said we
woke up this morning to a podcaster we
respect talking about this conspiracy
theory and it was pretty surreal made us
feel like it was time to come out and
put an end to all this
now what the reasons they say is
basically stuff that was in the video
that
the whole theory that they have is
there's
plausible deniability in everything
that they do
but like them saying this is inspired by
motorcycle patches doesn't make any
sense because the only motorcycle
patches that look like this are nazi
[ __ ] that's inspired by this yeah
it's still a direct line back to the yes
so that
i would ask that i would ask that
because i was
he's the guy i spoke to their manager
said one one of the guys wants to even
get on a call with me and i would be
happy to talk to him i said sure i'd
love to talk to him
one thing i'd love to see is show me
show me what you're talking about show
me these emblems
that are look like this that aren't
associated with nazis absolutely i mean
like i said i am not a
professional motorcycle club researcher
here i'm just a guy on google for 30
minutes looking around
but i looked at a lot of emblems
there's several sites that have whole
like databases to you know to identify
the different groups and yada yada yada
and the only ones that i stumbled upon
that looked like that logo are from
straight up aryan nation neo-nazi
motorcycle club so
you know i'm happy to be
shown something
else
from you know a uh
non-outlaw uh or non-racist motorcycle
club that uses that sort of design but
yeah it's definitely uh
and to be honest at first i was
suspicious i was like
there's got to be a bunch of emblems
that look just like this and you could
easily be like well it's this not you
can make a false connection
but i'm not seeing any other st any
evidence that this isn't connected to
that so that's the first thing a lot of
people in the chat are saying the logo
is the least of the problem you gotta
watch the video because there's a lot
more i've watched the video we've all
watched no i think they're just saying
to the other people listening yeah well
he addressed some other points so i just
want to go over the stuff that he said
um
right
now again the yuga labs thing is like so
[ __ ] up too
and he just told me the same thing about
yuga being a zelda boss it's a zelda
references that turns uh
yeah it's a zelda box that turns 3d
people into 2d correct which is clever
and cool
but the other thing is surf the the uh
yuga kylie
the kali yuga yes surf the kali yuga
which is like a
known
[ __ ] nazi white supremacists saying
like it's not like it's more like just
general alt-right i would say that yeah
okay yeah all general alt-right [ __ ]
surfing the kali yuga
and like there's no
way that they're not aware of that and
so they go yuga
yeah
yuga industry you got labs
right
it's just that's just a coincidence i
could write that one off as a
coincidence right
i'll be honest you know
i do actually think that a lot of the
points that they made are a stretch and
especially after looking into it like
you know they try and make this point
about the jagged edge of the logo but
that not really being the case
and yeah i mean a lot of them their
plausible deniability
uh that they have for a lot of the
points made um makes sense to me the one
that doesn't
and why i think both ethan and i are
focusing on so much
is that logo i mean i'm sorry
like if you try it
there was
part of their explanation is that they
had the anti-defamation league look into
this and sign off on it not
them not being nazis or whatever and i
actually have a quote
um
mark pittcavage a senior research fellow
at the adl center for extremism who has
on many occasions been called an expert
in court cases uh tells input that's the
publication that wrote this article that
he sees no connection between the board
ape yacht club logo and the nazi toten
conf image the nazi token comp is one
very specific graphic design of skull
and crossbones pit cabbage says and the
monkey skull resembles it in no way
insofar as all skulls resemble each
other to a certain degree
i don't know what that's so [ __ ] that
guy is talking about
and peace and love to the
anti-defamation league but i'm pretty
sure y'all are [ __ ] boomers who don't
know anything about 4chan i i mean again
these are supposedly people let's look
at a picture of mark searching this
something real quick some people in chat
are so stupid i'm saying yoga is in
zelda that's it i'm not defending
these guys i'm just saying it isn't
zelda yeah wait what what are people
people are saying it's not in zelda and
all capital i don't know
why but it is and it's the boston
celtics it's a boston zone no confirmed
it's a boss in zelda it's an obscure
boss in an obscure zelda game
his name is yuga that's that's known yes
that's that that's i've been using him
many times
now this is a zelda lore
by the way this is the guy who's the
wrote the memo
and like i mean again i
it could be that he's a master of
internet culture
but somehow i just doubt it
i just i just somehow doubt that this
guy i mean that and that statement is so
frustrating because it's just like it's
somebody telling you not to believe
what's directly in front of your phone
yeah you know what i mean it's like it
[ __ ] and i'm pretty sure and this
this is purely speculation so
take this with a grain of salt but i'm
pretty sure someone with deep hollywood
ties and lots of leverage and connection
could get this kind of statement out of
that of the uh you know anti-defamation
league yeah perhaps just a little
scratching my back kind of situation so
that statement is dumb so the people who
created this whole thing
it's a group of people four dudes okay
i mean is there a chance that like three
of them don't know that the fourth guy
is a nutty and they're like i don't
think so oh i would say there's
maybe a chance well so one of the guys
his name is uh this was another thing he
addressed so
his name is gargamel
which is the villain from the smurfs
that's long been known to be a jewish
anti-semitic stereotype
so his name is gargamel and not only
that but on 4chan gargamel is synonymous
with jew this is just wait so who is
that's one of the owners his name
pseudonym which is people don't know the
real names that's the guy
so i said what's the deal with the
gargamel yeah and he told me he looks
like gargamel oh and i said well i said
you know what no
he does kind of look like gargamel
that's him yeah hold on take a look
but like still i that's but again it's i
think that's a plausible deniability
thing
he does look like garmin and he's not
going to say he doesn't look like let me
show you he sent me photos of him elo
that are not public and you look at them
and tell me he doesn't look like
gargoyles but i don't care right i said
the same thing to dan that he does kind
of look like him and dan gave me a good
explanation as to why
it's important because uh 4chan like
it's a common meme on there well yeah i
mean you know they have lots of horrible
words for jews on 4chan they get thrown
around a lot of time and gargamel is
definitely one that i've seen thrown
around over the years everybody knows
yeah and it you know speaking of the
possible deniability i actually searched
around 4chan to see how they are
responding to this documentary and they
of course yeah stupid and it's you know
leftist [ __ ] blah blah blah
and i saw people saying um oh you know
that's [ __ ] gargamel isn't even like
a thing on 4chan or whatever um
i i went into like the archives and just
searched for the word darker male there
there are so many results well i saw
threads there's threads that um yeah is
on the original website where they're
like yo this guy's [ __ ] based this is
all like a 4chan alt-right shout out
yeah
which
and that's the thing i mean 4chan is a
big website there's lots of people on it
and not everybody you know is on the
same page or is aware of it so
people saying i'm a forechanner i i
no
but enough to
to be able to research it
the gargamel one is like just in your
face obvious yeah he does look like
gargamel though you know what i mean so
again it's pretty good plausible
deniability
but i don't know here look at these
photos he sent me they're not public but
i want you to see them and tell me if it
changes your mind at all
but what does i mean i already admit
that he looks
it yeah i like i see it
uh
okay
yeah i mean
i get it yes
he does kind of look like gargamel
so yeah
um
he also told me that um
they don't even use 4chan which i don't
think is is that guy uh jewish do you
know one of them is apparently jews no
the gargamel guy i don't think that's
the jew
one of the four dudes is jewish and the
manager who i spoke to is israeli jewish
he's definitely not a nazi doesn't
matter but yeah he's not in the inner
circle yeah and he has a huge vested
interest in
making sure that this project doesn't go
belly up
can i say i
i personally
don't think
that
any of those four guys are actually
nazis
um
i do however think that they are trolls
and think it's funny to incorporate edgy
imagery into things and sell it to a
main street a mainstream audience
now a lot of people will say well it
doesn't
matter you know if you're spreading that
kind of stuff around then you are a nazi
and okay fair enough but you know i
don't think
these guys are
uh white supremacists in my opinion why
because i think that they're just based
on what
well the fact that
uh i don't think any of them are white
um
and
so
yeah i get it but
but like i i don't i don't understand
it's like you don't put this [ __ ] unless
you [ __ ] at least a little bit
are anticipated
you're at least comfortable with the
imagery you think it's funny i don't
know
are you doing like a devil's advocate
kind of thing no that is my honest
opinion i don't think that they are they
are uh like
you know
actual
i think white supremacists that are
hoping for just like maybe
but it shouldn't matter
as my point right and that's fair uh i i
acknowledge that point that you know
whether or not you actually believe in
it it maybe is irrelevant um
i just personally because if you put it
you're doing it for the lulls more than
they are sure these are grown-ass people
it's just it's it's creating a whole hub
for real nazis to
to feel legitimized and like they have a
community
that's legit yeah and i i still think
it's harmful for sure so i don't think
it's harmful so therefore it doesn't
matter right the outcome is the same i
don't think it matters if they're trolls
or if they're actually you know
alt-righters or whatever it is yeah it
doesn't really matter but let's keep
going we've got the logos
we've got the biker thing we've got so
gargamel
is uh the name of this one guy
then you've got the other one's name is
gordon goner
now tell me if you think this one's a
stretch gordon goner
is a
pseudonym
or an anagram for drogo negro
which in what language is that
well it the drogo it's uh slang and it's
australian slaying that means like a
dumber idiot
basically stupid
and negro here it is black in a lot of
languages so spanish for example yeah it
just means dumb black
basically
it's an ant but so it's an anagram
though so i don't know if that's a
stretch or what
yeah i mean is it an anagram for
uh anything else
that's a good one we could put it in an
anagram let's do that's a good point
let's go to anagram
calculator let's put in dro uh gordon
goner and see what other anagrams come
up if there's other [ __ ]
he says he picked the name because it
sounds like joey ramon that makes no
sense to me what the [ __ ]
yeah that's what that's what his
official explanation is sorry what yeah
but they this guy says that the group
often uses anagrams
and he says it doesn't sound like joey
ramon at all which is right
yeah
apparently drogo is a common 4chan an
australian slang for stupid
yeah
so art did you find the anagram cut i
did in this stupid well that i found is
allowing for extra letters to be put in
which is not helpful at all so what the
[ __ ] is the point of that
um
but again it's an anagram i mean that's
such a deep
that's such it's not only an anagram
it's like a used term
oh for real
people use the first part the dumb part
no but you still have to scramble the
letters to get to
the
drogo
oh yeah okay but that is important
drogo negro is a term that people use
it's a known term uh
i don't know about that yeah i don't
think it really is i think it's just i
mean the drogo thing is
just the word using the word drogo um
but i just i'm
i think
in this day and age we all need to need
to listen more to our gut feeling
and my gut feeling is there there's too
many coincidences here it is for this
not to mean something
so
if one of you guys the founders is a fan
of ours
um
i suggest you guys do some internal
investigation
and
maybe one of you guys didn't mean for it
to be that but there's definitely a
meaning here thing is all of their names
have implications that's why people
think it's a form yeah like one of the
other co-founder so you have gilgamesh
that one's obvious you've got gordon
goner
gargamel whatever gilgamesh different
character yeah the epic of gilgamesh and
then the other one's name is emperor
tomato ketchup
which is the exact name of an explicit
film in 1971
that features a scene of a boy in a
fascist uniform r-wording an adult bride
the original film is banned in the us
and other countries on the grounds of c
word uh
cp
um i don't know how that one connects to
nazism to be honest it's just
is there like a
uh the japanese were allies with uh
germany and we're working yeah like the
movie well they was wearing a like
fascist imperial japanese
uniform
and i guess has some themes about that
kind of stuff in the film is to emperor
tomato ketchup some kind of like known f
uh
nod you know what i mean like it needs
to be
here it says mr way testified that
officer
purchase told him the films were fine
and that he would not be pressing
charges
he testified that officer purchase said
it's just a bunch of naked boys running
around on a beach or in a sauna
mr way says officer puccia showed him a
film he was selling called emperor
tomato ketchup and focused on two parts
of the film mr way testified that one
part showed a naked boy slapping and
massaging a woman's breast the other
part showed two naked adult women
massaging the boy's back
and
running a feather over his
uh private part
mr way testified the emperor tomato
ketchup was the line not to be crossed
mr way says he understood that as long
as he fell
under this threshold he would not be
breaking the law
and he relied on this advice the emperor
tomato ketchup is no longer available
so mike does this have any other
relation to anything other than that one
movie
yeah so uh there is a
album that is titled the same thing the
album is named after the movie
um
they claim that his name is in reference
to that album not to the movie
um but yeah the the album got it from
the movie so
you know indirectly it is still tied to
that uh by the way an australian fan of
ours donated 20 aussie dollars and said
it's pronounced uh drongo
drongo uh yeah like did you guys ever
find an anagram thing because i really
want to do all these websites suck yeah
and no
like they they just spit out angrams but
they don't use all the letters or they
add extra letters
there's no
14
or however many it is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11. no 11 letter words that
work so yeah
and then finally this other guy
goes by the name s-a-s-s
sas
sas
was a nazi party original para military
wing but do you think that's really a
nod to the ss
that's the sa and the ss it's combining
the two it's
i see
combining the two together into a name
which yeah i mean again a lot of these
on their own
uh definitely feel like a stretch i
think the argument that
people are saying is that um
all of it in totality is what makes it
so suspicious apparently they had this
rolling stone magazine and here
they depict a rat with gold which is
apparently like they think a nod to
anti-semitism is that a stretch i don't
know
a rat with gold it is kind of weirdly
i mean everything here is random and
crazy though
right
a rat with gold
you know are we are we looking too deep
i don't know
so
also the hand there
well yeah what was the significance of
the monkey hand again
it's uh
leopard leopold the great or whatever
his name is he kind of did some
i don't know i'm not too during the
colonial
era oh hear this the belgians uh owned
uh the congo and they were extremely
brutal and one of the things that they
would do is if
to punish people is to cut off their
hands
um the the people that live there
and so the
ape hand is you know first of all the
claim is that it's racist because it's a
reference to black people being apes
which is obviously a racist stereotype
that's been around for a long time and
the fact that it's cut off
is a reference to leopold's uh brutal
um punishment that
the overall the thing is like
alt-right people nazis they really hate
black people and jews they do indeed and
that's kind of what's going on here
uh that there's
so much imagery
that draws back to that
um and what was the other things he told
me i asked him a few
it's like everything with them has to be
such a
edgy
edgy reference
i don't know they seem like edge lords
for sure yeah but that's right yeah for
sure but like
somehow it's all related to nazi and
and cp
just to add it in there yeah
well that's the only reference to cpa
yeah
but um so then the other thing he said
is the artist
who put this all together ryder rips
he says himself is a giant troll
and he's just like a giant piece of [ __ ]
and he's doing this all
he's the sole
architect of this whole thing
this is his website
and he just did this to sell his own
nfts which is interesting because
this guy writer rips made a whole nft
project
called writer rips boy
uh uh board ape club he says you can get
an ape
without all the nazi [ __ ] and did he
just clone theirs like identical yeah
yeah the whole code is how is he not
being sued by them well he it got taken
dmc aid right so they're not on openc
anymore but people can still trade in it
or no
yeah good question yeah open c just
works as a
like a way to display the crypto or like
the
bitchin no it's called blockchain uh but
there's other websites who can do that
display the blockchain
but it's removed from it's open sorry
well what was interesting is he's
actually selling a lot of these
we figured he we calculated he made like
what like 70 000 bucks or something from
that at least 70 000 because that's how
many he confirmed uh selling at the mint
uh but he probably sold all of them yeah
this is his logo by the way it says it's
two oh here this logo is based on the ss
toten cough 18 teeth
it's pretty good
right so his whole like stealing it i
think uh from what i could understand
was a supposed to be drawing attention
to you know his accusations against the
the real version of it and also
sort of a commentary on the whole nft
thing because you know the whole
argument is like you know and nfts can't
be duplicated and there's only one of it
and he's like oh here i'm just going to
sell these exact same things so
it's also sort of a critique on that
um to an extent
but but he's that's the guy who put
together the yeah website we were
writing yeah and then he launched his
own parody that he's actually selling
though and making a lot of money up one
thing to consider is that he gets zero
percent on the resales and the board
apes get 2.5 on every resale
so it's a little bit different in that
regard because that's a big way that
these guys make their money i think
but um
but he is still making money and it says
here in his description
he says you can't copy an nft conceptual
art by ryder ribs somebody in the chat
he he said in all caps he's not
profiting from it um
really
if you actually know something that we
don't yeah we're happy to hear it yeah
because people are buying these with
money so where's the are with the real
ethereum so where's the yeah people
definitely bought them but what he did
with the money i don't know maybe he
donated it to something yeah if anybody
and there's further information on that
i'm happy to hear it yeah
someone says he's not actually selling
it or he gets sued for ip i mean they're
he's definitely selling them you can
come here somebody's literally look
some people are asking why are you
wearing this shirt so much i love this
shirt
it's comfortable it looks good i love my
shirt
teddyfresh.com of course
get it there
so nice
love it
i was this morning getting dressed i was
like i'm not going to wear it again it's
like i'm going to [ __ ] wear it again
it's my birthday i [ __ ] you for it like
three times this week
what's the end game someone asked were
the buyers in on the nazism or was it
trolling crypto bros there's no end game
they're just
they're just giving a shout out to their
to their homies that's it
you know
it's just trolling yeah just trolling i
mean
um so i don't know you know
he's he claimed he says this guy ryder
rip is a giant piece of [ __ ]
but we didn't really find much
controversy about him did we dan
um well i found an interesting
factoid about him which is that he was
engaged to azealia banks last year for
like a month and they re made a audio
sex tape together which he sold as an
nft for like 17 grand which is
one of the weirdest sentences i've ever
said in my life
yeah i mean i don't consider that
it's interesting but i don't think it's
anything bad i was trying to find this
4chan
uh thread of them being like yo this
[ __ ] is based as [ __ ]
it was in here wasn't it
here's the 4chan thread check this out
so the for these people in fortune
started realizing that this is actually
a shout out to them holy [ __ ] board 8
yacht club is a secret esoteric
hitlerism dog whistle get in here now
[ __ ] based
yugo labs the creators of board yacht
club was questioned
as to the meaning of yuga he said it's a
character from zelda but the twitter
lefties are not buying they instead
found out about yuga as kali yuga
um and now they're going schizo mode
delving into the symbolism of board apes
and basically confirming that board 8
yacht club is [ __ ] based lefty nft
twitter is having a full
discussion on the hit em racism and it's
awesome
schizo mega thread showing connections
lots of salt in here guys keck
talking about the prevalence of my
racism and my all-right
and the web 3 space
please post salt and cringe
this is all [ __ ] great this is why
they do it right i mean
it looks like and this guy's saying he
agrees that's what's interesting it
looks like bored api club is based
they're like yeah this shit's true i
mean it's just one guy right but
this is this is why they do it
that's gross
yeah i mean why don't they just change
their their logo that's that's what
confused me
did we write this page just carefully
scrolling oh good idea yeah i would be
very good yeah
i'm out good point
um
oh yeah then the other thing is like
board ape yacht club was
launched on hitler's death day
including their other project the other
side
and white nationalists and neo-nazis
they loved that [ __ ] his death day and
birthday
well the birthday see uh that was
another one that you know the people
that are trying to
shout this all down say
that's not true they don't celebrate
hitler's death day they celebrate his
birthday
um i don't know i don't know many
neo-nazis so i don't know if they
celebrate his death day or not i mean i
guess i get what they're saying i it
wouldn't be a happy day to somebody that
likes hitler for whatever god forsaken
reason
um but it is
as they pointed out in the documentary
they they seem to have gone out of their
way to launch it on that date which
again on top of all of the other things
is just like one more to the pile of
strange coincidences so and then the
other thing i talked to the guy about
that he tried to dissuade me from
is this one issue of there's this one
ape
number 18 what is it number 1844 or
something
oh 1488. okay there's a there's an ape
on 1488.
okay let me pull that up
1488. now ela i want to show this to you
you tell me what you think so here is
the actual ape 1488 now the significance
of 1488
dan you can explain this is their
favorite alphanumerics it's adolf hitler
and hail hill no no the 14 is actually a
reference to the 14 words oh yeah the
fourteen words the sort of like mantra
and the white supremacist neo-nazi
things that i will not repeat on the
show
and um and then 88 is h uh heil hitler
okay don't sound bite that zach
oh
please don't
so then
what they said here is that in
cryptology you remove zeros so
if you remove the zeros it says 1987.
now in 1987
i was born
me too
a famous nazi died in 1987.
and it seems really so i typed 18 1987
knots oh my symbolism
rudolph hess is the first thing that
comes up
and he goes dude so what he told me
about that is like what's the deal with
19
87 and nazis die every year they're
coming and going we had a nazi died in
2016. it's meaningless yeah
so i said okay you know
he's right it's and when i first heard
this i thought it was a stretch
so when you type 1987 nazi this guy
comes up and this is a thing by the way
again in the nazi white supremacist
world is 1987. so if you type any other
year like 1950 nazi
it's all kind of random [ __ ] like give
me any year it doesn't it doesn't strike
the same 82
1982
it's not it's not the same thing you see
okay when you type 1987 it goes straight
to this guy's wikipedia page
rudolph hess
leading member of the nazi party
hitler's last living henchman dies
so this is like a celebrated again year
to them like give me any year 19 1989
nazi
oh there you go adolf hitler came up on
1989. shout out
maybe they should have done that one
so i don't know is it a stretch i don't
know
what do you think but he said well it's
just too [ __ ] random that was his
thing on the 1987.
i don't know
there you have it
and basically he was just saying that uh
they're good guys
they're all bernie supporters
that uh you know they're crushed by this
accusations it's totally [ __ ] so
where is the like
where is the serious apology and like
denouncing
well they put it they put out this
morning yeah they put out this morning
i'll read it
just this morning yeah as you may have
heard we've become the target of crazy
disinformation campaign accusing us a
group of jewish turkish pakistani and
cuban friends are being super-secret
nazis
even though the adl which exists to
protect jewish people around the world
has confirmed it isn't true i feel like
that is just
that's just a bullsh that's like a paid
for statement i mean it's so stupid
it just
so anyway i'm totally ignoring that
paragraph has confirmed this isn't true
trolls are still spreading ridiculous
conspiracy theories online using them to
sell knockoff nfts
we've uh responded to much of the
[ __ ] before here and here
uh others have come out and called this
out in a detailed way
i saw this thread it's not interesting
it's the same [ __ ] that didn't we've all
heard that compelling yeah i read that
as well
we've not responded in further detail
these allegations because frankly
they're insanely far-fetched
now i don't think it's insanely
far-fetched i i don't and i'm not i'm
not a conspiracy theorist there is a
weird no it's not there is a weird thing
going on here
like if they were genuine i think they
would be like this these are total
coincidences and we're going to change
it right
but to just write it off as far-fetched
and then throw out this [ __ ] bought
and paid for statement by the adl
i don't know let's keep reading
that said we woke up this morning to a
podcaster we respect talking about this
conspiracy theory and that was pretty
surreal made us feel like it was time to
come out put an end to this so here it
goes why does our nft collection feature
apes there's a long history of people
affectionately referring themselves as
apes in the crypto world which is why
some of the rest are most valuable nfts
and crypto punk collection which dates
back to 2017 are called apes or our apes
we like the idea of creating a whole
collection around apes
who became so wealthy because of
crypto's rise that they became extremely
bored what is the board ape to do
perhaps retreat
to a secretive club in the swamp
again this was presented already in that
video
uh what's what's his name again
the person who made the video yeah uh
phelion yes
what is it pheleon
oh yeah
yeah phillion
presented all these counter arguments in
his video
what was the inspiration for the design
we never wanted to take ourselves too
seriously so the look of the club is
ramshackle and divy everything about the
board yacht club was meant to convey a
spirit of irreverence and absurdity it's
a yacht club that's actually falling
apart and smack dab in the heart of the
everglades as such it needed an
opportunity an appropriately grimy
intriguing logo
we went with an ape skull to help convey
just how bored these apes are
they're bored to death
okay
also by the way
board ape yacht club there was like a
really prominent uh
group where they posted nazi memes
called the
kala yuga surf or kala yuga surf club
right or something like that
that was before this
kali yuga surf club
which was like nazi
uh a private nazi group on
uh one of these alt-right what unlike
whatever
so the similarity that that is
so they go here below is gordon's email
to the designer we work with on the logo
laying out our inspiration punk
streetwear skate references
maritime flags
penance old yacht club flags
what does the old yacht cub flag look
like can you see if there's anything
that resembles this board yacht club is
a flag so having a version of the logo
that was a patch made sense to us and we
borrowed from other yacht club logos
okay and motorcycle club patch designs
so we looked at those i feel like we
pretty much debunked that claim
but let's what does yacht club logos
look like
uh
yacht club logos i mean they said
i mean
it's circular black and white
it doesn't look anything like [ __ ]
the nazi that you should mistake for a
nazi symbol no not at all none of these
no no none of these either
yeah they just threw that in there but
this is their attempt at plausible
denied ability if you ask me that didn't
make it it's not hidden well and if they
had an outside if that's true they had
an outside designer make this logo and
there's an email
they sent back a bunch of options and
they just picked from you know a board
um okay maybe you guys got trolled then
you know you got tricked into but no
because it's in the throughout the whole
thing yeah no i mean but if they got
trolled they they should be like yo this
they're right this looks just like the
nazi thing
here's the email he apparently sent
in march
20 and 21. i'd like to see a maritime
flag
with border yacht club in it a maritime
flag that doesn't look anything like
what it ended up being
yeah well
i mean they could have started with all
kinds of inspiration they didn't go with
it though what they ended up going with
is the nazi one looking like a nazi yeah
yeah but like what does a maritime flag
look like this is all that came up
yeah i mean yeah those are it's just a
nation's flag of nations yeah
so
there's there's no so it says
um
i tried making one with the shitty
vector and i downloaded off the internet
to give you the general vibe we are no
longer interested in the x's though we'd
rather see dots
one of the main inspiration for this is
an image directly below
which he didn't include
a vintage maritime club
go down
oh these this is what he attached yeah
bro there's literally no resemblance to
the final product here
maybe this skull crossbone here
yeah but this is not this doesn't look
anything like the nazi one nope
which is a very specific look to it
yeah so
one of the main inspirations
is the vintage maritime club we love the
overall look
enjoy the font as far as inspiration i
see a long history of maritime related
patches he's going on and on about
maritime there's no resemblance i'd like
you to i'd like for you to think of the
logo from the perspective of a
skateboard streetwear hip-hop japanese
anime clothing brand and less strictly
from a this is a bar
for crypto apes
they're height beat nut beats
what what happened did i know it's just
funny
i'm [ __ ] stupid jesus christ
it occurs to me uh no though that i the
name board a yacht club isn't featured
in either of the ideas i've mentioned
this is potentially problematic maybe
versions where they are shown spelled
out it would be interesting to see board
eight bianca spelled out in a retro 60s
cursive similar to bathing ape jacket
below the barrel this this email does
nothing
it does nothing to absolve you of any
yeah
it's completely irrelevant it's a
convenient you know to include here it's
completely irrelevant
yeah it doesn't show anything
okay
oh so wait okay wait he's obviously i
suck at mocking stuff up so he sent them
this
on a poker chip
or like a buoy yeah i think it's like uh
it looks like a buoy
so wait but this this is something he
may have just made i mean yeah i think
that was the one he was explaining that
he made right
yeah
he made it for the designer right
okay
i'm sure our trolls will find a way to
tie the bsbc
pen in here to other stuff something
hateful it's literally just some vintage
cub flat flag we found
here's the file name we have for vintage
club flag blue framed
dude what
what is this supposed to do for me
you're the p i think they're they're
mock they're saying
try and find something wrong with this
it's this is code two
they're being sarcastic is my point i
think
okay
well
since the border biakov logo has become
a main point for this troll it's worth
laying out what the anti-defamation
league had to say in the subject this is
the and let me remind you as i read the
quote of this guy what he looks like
the keeper of internet culture
and 4chan lore
at the aclu
no uh
adl adl whatever here
now maybe he maybe he is really versed
with
internet culture
looks like he's more versed with
delivering presents to children well i
have no doubt december
i have no doubt he has extensive uh
uh history researching far-right groups
and everything like um he has a claim
too but yeah i wouldn't expect this guy
necessarily to understand like chan
culture
so he says the nazi token cough is one
very specific graphic design of a skull
and crossbone and the monkey skull
resembles it in no way except so far as
the skulls resemble each other to a
certain degree
they've parading this statement around
and it's really meaningless it's a whole
lot of nothing it's really good
yeah he's just comparing the actual
skull not the whole logo i think
like just the skulls maybe they just
showed them to school i don't know
because this analysis makes no sense
talk about the the company name you go
lags they just say it's from zelda yeah
what's what the inspiration for the
founders pseudonyms
we came up with the pseudonyms on the
fly right before launching we wish we
spent more time on it because it's weird
and hilarious to get on a meeting with
important people and say hi i'm tomato
emperor tomato ketchup is the name of
this album which is of course a
reference to that move to that film
right well let me ask you this the
people who named their album tomato and
for tomato ketchup were they a weirdo
group like what's the deal with the band
isn't it like stereo lab or something
it's like a stereo lab serial love you
i don't know who they are uh they're
like kind of a indie pop band from the
90s
well if they can name their band after
this movie and people don't think
they're a nazi then so can he but
true
it's a good record it was ranked 51 on
pitchfork's last 50 best albums
okay
no sass chose his name because gordon
can get very sassy in the morning with
him and it became an inside joke
no sad no sass okay
gordon goner garner came from the fact
that gordon was sick and in out of
hospital a lot over the past 10 years
over the course of what she started to
think to himself i'm a goner
also he thought that the name gordon
goner sounded cool like joey ramone what
the [ __ ] does that mean
this whole explanation makes notes this
is a throwaway [ __ ] yeah gordon
goner
joey ramone
there's no resemblance why do they keep
saying that big ramones fan dude
and then gargamel gar so this guy is the
most blatant one uh gargamel
shows his pseudonym because he's a fan
of starcraft
and hates smurfs
oh no hell no
i played starcraft that smurfs is people
who come in playing at lower yeah
dude that's [ __ ] the biggest [ __ ]
that's like the that's [ __ ]
it refers to refer people that's a new
explanation i thought it was just
because he looked like him that's what
he told me
which is how you refer to people who
cheat the latter system in the game yeah
i played a lot of starcraft i never
heard nobody used that we got
inconsistency in the story between one
he told you that's true that is true i
haven't read the whole paragraph yet but
but but that this this is a manufactured
uh reason they're it's so obvious and
the previous one was a whole pile of
[ __ ] yeah uh this is why his bio on
the board ape yacht club was just
starcraft obsessed eats smurfs
in addition he found out shortly before
bardet yacht club launched that his wife
had never seen the show smurfs which he
thought was crazy so they started
watching it back then plus his friend
always rip on him prematurely for
balding so they they do mention okay
right
by itself it's fine but in connection
with everything it's it's [ __ ]
i just don't
i can't
i
have such a hard time getting past the
logo thing and how they're not just like
we're sorry we didn't make the
connection yeah now that it's been
pointed out to us yeah exactly obviously
we're going to change the like it just
seems like they say it's far-fetched
it's not yeah it's not which just like
yeah it's also like
it's just kind of reminding me like i we
haven't finished it but it doesn't sound
like they are very
passionately saying how much they're
against like nazi
right agenda that's true they just kind
of say it as a given like of course
we're not nazis yeah we are uh not white
we're we're turkish in pakistan
it's not satisfying to me and also it
reminds me of trump after that
charlottesville
march and he was like there's good
people on both sides
i don't know there wasn't like enough
i'm not with this people well i don't
know anything about these guys you can
tell me he's jewish they're anonymous i
don't know anything about them he might
be jewish he might not i don't know
i don't nobody knows his real name
as far as i'm aware
none of the founders are good at cipher
or puzzles okay cool case closed we're
awful at them we had to bring in
professional help in the form of a
company called exultation of larks by a
brilliant guy named greg pliska to help
create the board yacht club treasure
hunt all the answers to the treasure
uh hunt were ape or monkey related
because duh
so this is he's saying these are the
other claims of the troll site each more
ridiculous than the last
i noticed they started calling him garga
no use the whole name
gargamel worked as a book editor for
many years and gordon is a big fiction
buff it's been our job to think deeply
about narratives and stuff like
hemingway's iceberg theory or whitten
wittgenstein also yes garga wrote his
senior thesis on roberto blanos one of
the most famous and celebrated latin
american authors over the last 50 years
and apparently i don't know anything
about this author but he's like a nazi
or some [ __ ]
is that right who's this robert bolano
let's see
i
don't remember it was mentioned in the
documentary but garbellano is a chilean
novelist
yeah it was in here that he was
here nazi literature let's see
literature in america
is an entirely fictious ironic
encyclopedia of fascist latin american
and american writers and critics
blinded to their own mediocracy and
sparse who cares
boarded yacht club did not launch on
hitler's death day a reporter got the
date wrong in an early article and the
trolls have run with it ever since
second whoever considered the day hitler
died when starting a company
oh no you tell me yeah it's stupid don't
don't ask me just tell me just tell me
[ __ ] don't
this [ __ ] makes me think that you guys
are lying yeah who would ever think of
that
but okay so the the reporter got wrong
one of the most insane things was when
this troll posted about garga's wife
insinuating that she was all right
because she had the word cowabunga in
her instagram bio
garga's wife is mexican-american and she
likes the ninja turtles like millions of
people
so what was the thing with cowabunga
uh
cowabunga was another thing that was
used on 4chan a lot for referencing like
the kickoff of a civil war or like a
race war here in the united states um
yeah i mean
okay
maybe that might be a stretch i don't
know exactly i mean
they can't take cowabunga from us yeah
it did they took the freaking a-ok sign
right which would started out as a troll
as well um
you know
and
yeah there's a lot of similarities to
that situation overall we think it's
crazy that these conspiracy theories
have been able to proliferate it really
shows the power of a demented troll on
the internet can have is this what i
don't like yeah
because it's really not that dumb and
trust me they're acting like this is
like flat earth level dumb
yeah yeah
we've seen our community rally behind us
well of course because they're invested
that's what i'm saying like they're in
your ponzi scheme dude yeah they're
literally
their life is tied up in this large
financial interest to not have this uh
spread we've seen our community rally
behind us and we appreciate that it's
obvious to them as well to anyone we've
worked with over the past year not to
mention anyone who has known us our
whole lives well we don't know who you
know
yeah i don't know nobody's anyone's
supposed to know you yeah exactly yeah
trust trust me my friends love me your
neighbor yeah i don't care about your
neighbor it's all nonsense we appreciate
all the love and support i mean this is
a nothing burger yeah
this whole thing in my opinion
but what do you guys think i mean that's
basically it
um
well let's do a poll what do you guys
think is it all a coincidence or
or
is there something going on here oh i'm
getting text by oh or is there no
such thing as a coincidence there's no
such thing as a coincidence you're
getting texts by uh the guy that you
spoke with yeah watching in real time he
might be
i'm not gonna say anything because i
know these guys are
private and i don't wanna
uh
um
so this is one of the
one of the founders
is
is uh texting me
one of the founders or or no one
okay i'm not so if you're watching don't
panic i'm not going to read it
so the manager put me in a text group
with one of the founders got it
is it uh
gargle these nuts
it's gordon goner it's gord and goner
the chat has been spamming uh gargle
these nuts ever since
i felt the need to uh acknowledge
okay
let's see
[Music]
i'd love to to talk if this guy wants to
do an interview that would be awesome
like he doesn't have to show his face
but he what he's saying basically
is that him and his family have been uh
on the receiving end of harassment and
conspiracy conspiracies by this guy
which i'm obviously extremely
sympathetic towards
and then when he saw us talking about it
he it destroyed him
so
he's so okay it seems like he's willing
to talk
which would be great if he if one of
these founders would hop on a call it
could really clear up the whole thing
right
i think if they are willing to
[Music]
passionately denounce
any nazi
notion
and any nazi members that may have
joined them since all of this if they're
willing to passionately say they
disapprove of any nuts okay okay that's
my opinion otherwise
not looking to help spread
nazi propaganda and then
like under the
guise of like we're just edgy
and funny well we'll we'll hit him we'll
hit we'll ask you know and not let him
get it but you were smiling had a [ __ ]
in grind damn what were you thinking
i i mean i think
this is a rare opportunity i can't
believe these guys are watching uh i
never thought i would be able to send a
message directly to the board yacht club
yeah dan is getting drunk with power i'm
having you guys come see their moment
with you no it's just it's just a trip
um this is how the sam cedar thing
happened listen i
like
i basically feel the way that gila was
just saying i i don't feel particularly
compelled to run interference for a
bunch of
people that are putting this kind of
stuff out into the world and you know if
if um
if it really is all coincidence
you really didn't mean to do any of this
um
you know
i think the right step is to probably
well first of all change your [ __ ]
logo that very obviously looks like a
[ __ ] ss symbol yeah duh like how is
that not just step number one
instead of just acting like everyone's
crazy
for seeing what's literally in front of
their [ __ ] face
and two
um your entire nft project is [ __ ]
awful man it's the ugliest thing oh come
on i just i i can't i can't i can't not
say that actually
what i don't know why all of a sudden
because i'm talking to them i feel like
i want to be friendly i've said that a
million times i [ __ ] hate the
but it doesn't mean they're nazis right
yeah these are separate big differences
these are separate issues dan i'm sorry
i'm sorry if you guys are watching dad
took the opportunity to say hey this is
not this is not
anything
personal it's just your your your
project sucks it's a light on society
and you know
i hope it fails
i really don't know they're already rich
i know i mean they already made their
billions or whatever so they're so rich
dude from this [ __ ] it's nuts
but yeah i mean i personally think
if he'd be willing to come on and give
us an interview he can be anonymous he
can even use a voice changer i don't
care and not show his face as long as he
confirms his identity
to us
i mean i know the guy i'm talking to is
legit dan can you explain something in
here what's up heil hitler
oh [ __ ] dude are you not in on this are
you
play that again we're gonna have to
discuss if you can use the exact uh yeah
i'm not kidding i don't know about this
look at dan's face i'm sorry guys
dan's the one that made it happen
everybody i didn't even think about it
don't forget rule number one and that is
listen to dan and i told you all
true
that's true
you have my word i will not
i think
if he'd be willing to come on and we can
talk about all this stuff
because that was a very pre-prepared
somewhat dismissive statement let's get
him on
let's talk to him let's have a
conversation and see
when when you know push comes to shove
so to speak
where it shakes out
right yeah
because if it because look
if he's telling the truth
and there's a chance he's telling the
truth and this guy and his family have
been on the receiving end of her of
harassment bowling that's horrible and i
sympathize with that i mean i know who
else is
jewish people and people of color
when nazi people try to kill them
right that's also true they're they're
receiving that
you know you guys there you go dealt
with directly that's that's why yeah we
deal i deal with the [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time these people who he who we
think they're giving a dog whistle to
are literally always harassing us let's
do a poll do you think it's a
coincidence
let's have three options
yeah maybe there's degrees of this uh
there's something going on here what do
you think
there is
something going on here
i'm not sure i'm not sure
and uh total coincidence totally oh
yeah that's like a mid like i can't make
up my mind
okay i'm throwing it up
see what the audience thinks it's yours
i think
it's oh it was bigger the white sauce
was good
all right pulls going
um well the people that think
something's going on there are by far
the biggest group at 83
wow 10 i'm not sure and
only it's actually
shifting a little bit but 5 currently on
it's just the total coincidence i want
to tell me the reason five percent
difference is astronomical
five percent means everything
yeah
i can't see five percent
76
are saying there's something going on
there you go so like i'm not the problem
i think you guys need to do more
explaining
because on the face
we have an issue here
and it's not just a crazy fringe thing
and i mean in this day and age
it's just you can't be [ __ ] around
with this no you can't because remember
only like a couple weeks ago the
who was in the fbi or police i don't
know they arrested a whole van of like
20 a [ __ ] clown car full of nazis
yeah [ __ ] was so wild
full of nazis with guns and everything
so like it's not a joke and
if you're actually not standing for it
why would you want these people in your
community why do you want to give them a
a club
you shouldn't so
i don't know if you really don't want
that you should make it more clear look
at these
these absolute [ __ ] goons yeah we
never talked about this all these
weirdly faces uh who think they're aryan
somehow super inbred
master race look at this guy in the top
right
the only thing you're a master of is
baiting jerking off your little tiny pig
dick
look at this guy bro what happened to
your face doing the blue steel doing the
love look a little bit that's what
happened when you [ __ ] your cousin three
times
three generations of cousin [ __ ]
i am of course
a white supremacist sometimes sometimes
you just open the back of a u-haul and
30 neo-nazis just kind of pile out all
of a sudden yeah they were going to a
pride parade
yeah there you go i'm sure they i'm sure
they were going there with good
intentions you know a pride parade in
the small town in idaho that my
girlfriend allison is from oh wow yeah
what do you think about that any insight
uh
she is well aware that that area of
idaho is full of literal nazis and it's
part of why she left
there's like a more
there's probably a better picture of all
of them can you find it yeah yeah
there's a they're like the greatest
faces
and in the worst way possible
not aryan at all
no wonder they're so angry
look at them
so
the guy who's uh texting you and
apparently is listening is this your
club you want to you want this guy's on
your club well he's saying it's a total
coincidence he won't even accept
anything well you have to you created a
club you created a community yo that guy
in the middle looks like a skyrim
character this one the one on the bottom
left yeah
he's really he's
somebody else pointed that out actually
i think yeah it was all over ready bro
he looks like a skyrim guard he looks
like he's
using a filter that like puts the you
know when it's like symmetrical and it
puts the same side on both sides
symmetrical king symmetrical thing
they all look like different versions of
each other also
he's like hey i'm symmetrical in my hate
i hate jews and black people just the
same
it's like a mirror image
yeah
so
what the [ __ ]
that's it is this your club show me more
of these guys i love it
up
oh my god that guy in the bottom right
there go down
that guy definitely date rapes
fraternity girls
this one
all of them somebody in the chat says
not beautiful
not beautiful
sorry not beautiful half of them look
like the pokemon evolved version of the
guy next to them
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes
jordan likes it i don't know why these
why are you guys so angry man it's
[ __ ] up like
why do these people exist it's just sad
you know
is it because their conditions are so
[ __ ] bad in life our government has
failed them
yeah
finding scapegoats
feeling alienated
pro-life
oh they're definitely yeah children of
oh no
we need yeah this is why we need
abortion
someone in chester these days tiny mouth
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
that dude looks like scuffed and jeff
whitake
which one
well it's obvious left dude this guy
they all look the same
that dude in the middle right now with
the longer area
looks like jeff whitak
you know i'm sure people like
from
southeast asia probably see all white
people and think they all look the same
huh
i mean
i do
yeah i'm looking at this right now i
can't i can't
there are like five of them to look
exactly like all these guys were
standing in a group and you had to
remember one of them i couldn't do that
i would just remember the skyrim guy
that's it there's like four base uh like
characters here and they kind of just
devolve from them yeah
they're four different prototypes they
need to work on their character creation
and it's [ __ ] awesome super outdated
no customization
so there you go what do you think should
i continue this conversation with these
guys
they're really adamant
i mean
he says literally not one claim against
us is true
if that's true then they gotta like
say stuff against it yeah change the
logo change your names
i'm gonna try to get him to call him i
think it'd be interesting to hear him
out to me especially the gordon gunner
name super suspicious that's the guy
who's texting me i know
i'm saying especially that's the the dog
that's the anagram one yeah
that's really funny thank you maybe put
in our chat we aren't ripped uh we
aren't racist crypto bros stand back and
stand by
that wasn't one of the bible yeah
you didn't they never denounced it right
they yeah didn't
they said we're target of crazy
disinformation well they just keep
saying their nationalities as if it
that's a foregone thing that it's like
we can't be nazis we're
pakistani we're turkish we're cuban and
it's like well first of all those are
nationalities not yeah you know race and
you know there can be white turkish
people
i mean there are definitely lots of
white cubans
the leader of the proud boys is like a
cuban dude in it
uh
oh the tortaro guy is he cuban or
whatever his name is um yeah you might
be right about that actually
uh but yeah it's um
you know
i think i think they need to do a little
bit more than just be like
give the i can't be racist i have black
friends
that's totally what you know what i mean
yeah
can i i mean they didn't cover the
boogerly
bugler boys uh
like shirt thing right did they respond
to that ever because that was kind of uh
what's that wait i'm not familiar with
that well it was that they were wearing
some of the board apes have a hawaiian
shirt that you know it's the same one
yeah literally this way can you give me
a time stamp on that one
i mean here i have the video i'll show
you
one of the board faces wearing the exact
same shirt as some boogaloo
which is a white they're like the proud
boys uh yeah the boogaloo boys are uh
they're just like violent white
supremacists well the
the boogaloo is in reference to
a joke that they have that they they are
hoping for they're accelerationists they
want a second american civil war and
they refer to it as the boogaloo
um lovely fun so the boogaloo boys and
they purposely dress really ridiculously
wait that's the guy i'm talking to in
the middle
uh yeah what did they say about him
anything
i wanted to know what they said about
him
about who the guy in the middle that's
the guy i'm talking to
oh oh oh uh
baby yacht club guy oseri and neil
strauss go back to 1998 when guy oseri
was featured in the credits of neil
strauss's biography on marilyn manson
one of the most mind-boggling parts to
this ongoing story is celebrity
endorsement yeah
i think that was at the tail end of it
i'm looking for wait i want to know
what's his conspiracy about guy oseri
because i'm sure this guy's not a nazi
but he basically just says that he's uh
he's the
person who got them into the celebrity
world oh that's just like that i'm sure
is true so i don't
if i don't mis remember i don't think
there's any conspiracy about him okay
yeah i just want to make sure because i
would i can confirm that that he's a
late uh latecomer um okay but that
that's true i don't think he would even
deny that that's the whole point of his
yeah i mean i don't think that was even
really part of the conspiracy he was
just kind of laying out who's behind the
company um
trying to find the damn hawaiian shirt
thing in my search function is taking me
to the wrong timestamp anybody else
wants to help me look for that
where the hell is it
yeah
i i want to find this i want to explore
this
can you send me the link i'll help look
for it too but
yeah it's uh right here
yeah
i mean if that rider rip a guy's making
all this up that's pretty insane like
this guy is some kind of genius
to be able to connect all these dots
it's nuts i mean he is another you know
internet troll kind of guy um but that
doesn't necessarily mean that he's
making this up but
uh i really don't sorry to interrupt go
ahead but i don't i don't really like
how he set up that nfts because yeah
almost like literally all nfts nowadays
are like trash
but especially when you don't promise
anything you don't back up your nft with
promises and stuff like that it's just
gonna it's like it's literally
completely speculational but and i think
this nft project is super speculational
it's gonna drop in price as fast as this
becomes unrelevant
and i kinda don't like that because all
the investors just going to lose all
their money and they're talking about
board ape or the knockoff the copy one
the knockoff one so
at the same time i think that's really
scummy to even do this because it's
gonna go to zero within a couple of
weeks i don't think anyone really
invested that much money though because
they sell for like what like 35 bucks or
something no through two
plus 300 bucks yeah
300 bucks
but it's like still that's i'm sure
there's people who i don't like he's
making money
that's why i want to know
there's for sure people who's going to
lose money on that that's basically what
i'm saying and i think that's not fair
even though it's a goof i'd have to yeah
i agree but i think i'd like to know if
he kept money or not because that that
makes a big difference
for sure we could try and reach out to
that guy too or at least philly i mean
he participated in that video with
fillion um and so you know here is um
this is the part by the way if you want
me to play it oh yeah go for it
club shirt is an exact boogaloo boy
hawaiian shirt used to larp by 4chan
users
okay but is that just a random dude in a
random shirt that he wore once
or is and also can you zoom in is that
the same shirt
or is it just similar it looks pretty
damn similar like what's on what's drawn
on the hoodie
i can't zoom
cam center still okay i got this still
yeah
got a donation uh from ray logix that
says please don't platform these guys
and give them space to be legitimized
there's no reason
to not lie to you and gaslight everyone
it could be harmful i mean
i i'll consider everything this is
leaves uh it's just leaves
so zoom in on the board ape that one
it's just like red shirt with leaves on
it
um
they look like leaves to me on this one
i would have to try and
screenshot this
because i want to make sure i don't want
to make sure they're not stretching
that's too blurry to really oh yeah it's
leaves
so yeah that's the same it's leaves i
found another person with that same
shirt
oh really
yeah you're right this is a different
guy
with the same shirt why are they wearing
that red with the leaves it's so random
is this the same guy
yeah
okay so check this out ela we found it
so this is a thing they actually wear
this shirt
well they wear the third one they wear a
lot of hawaiian shirts not specifically
that it's not like it's you found a
third one yeah he's right there's a
third one
[ __ ] love you've really you're right
this is the third separate occasion
they're wearing the same goddamn shirt
you know what's funny i always hated
hawaiian shirts
well it scared me as i have a shirt that
kind of looks like that
oh exactly why are they all wearing
goggles
is that the boogaloo thing like it's
just party time no it's so that it's
purposely so that they look ridiculous
so that when
people call them out
um
those people look crazy it's
again that's why people are not really
eager to give these guys the benefit of
the doubt because this the the whole
plausible deniability thing and
um
trying to make your critics look crazy
this is a tactic it's a tactic that's
known and so and you know
uh
that's crazy so look at this sheila
so here's one shirt that we've found now
three cases so this is the thing it's a
red shirt with leaves on it one two
three
now show the show the the drawing dan
the board ape one
it's a red shirt with leaves exactly the
same one
what's the chance of that no chance
that's the same exact character what the
[ __ ] the chance of that [ __ ] dude is
it possible that like the artist that
they're working with has beliefs that
they just don't know about or is it it's
like embedded in in the company
look anything's possible but the most
damning evidence oh no
oh [ __ ] really please bro literally my
heart stopped it was funny that was this
day i was i was making a joke like me
and i'm dressing like zach but hold on
one time you wear a hawaiian shirt but
hold on isn't it the thing red with
leaves hawaiian shirt maybe it's
i'm looking for it i can't find the same
one specific where'd they buy it it
really is so specific maybe where'd you
get it in blue
[Music]
i think it's a van's shirt i think i got
it from the van store
no yours is not that that it's not it's
not that no yeah they're just just
joking on you
but this one's pretty crazy coincidence
isn't it
what the [ __ ] it's not a coincidence
i will not describe it as a coincidence
should i ask him about this one yeah
because they didn't respond to that at
all i feel like that's kind of sexy yeah
that's a good point
can you here can you send me whatsapp
the three
image you found and then the board ape
so i'll send them all four images and
ask
yeah yeah what what's what's the
explanation there
yeah i don't know man not looking good
for the board ape club
i gotta i just gotta say that
there's just too much going on here
and what a shame if it all fell apart
what a loss
for civilization
is it blue birds or is it blue flowers
flowers we zoomed right in here look
look on my phone
leaves
yeah
and on his shirt is leaves
the eight
so oh wait you got four now oh no it's
the same one no i just
wait that's the same guy twice yeah i
saw that but there there's definitely
three individual ones
that's definitely yeah the ones earlier
in the chat okay yeah i got it i got it
so the ones uh the board apes i'm seeing
with the shirt i see a parrot in it too
in the shirt yeah
his does not have a parrot it's just
leaves
i found one that looked just like it oh
that's
that's the one 18
yeah you found it where is called no
boundaries men's hawaiian shirt
that's the one that they're all wearing
how the hell did you find that ela i
found it sun
i don't know that i want to spread it
around
i'll show you guys
yeah ela found it
so huh yeah that's it can you send the
ape so i can send all dan did you have
the full picture of the ape i can't find
it
oh i just screenshotted it from here
where did that ape come from that
drawing yeah so interestingly enough i
looked at the the actual clothes that's
in the nft this is some kind of a promo
picture
but the
the nfts themself doesn't have the same
shirt which is weird
so it's just in some promotional artwork
but yeah use that particular design
which works in favor for them obviously
a little bit
they still did it though
yeah this is what i was talking about
with love so this is what i
what i saw the parrot yeah
all right well i'll send it to them and
get back to you guys because actually we
got to get going
how long we've been going dan for christ
uh three and a half hours oh my goodness
that's a birthday bonanza guys it's a
birthday bonanza well thank you for all
the birthday wishes
everybody
and thank you guys that shirt is also on
ebay
appreciate the pizza and the cake what a
choice
what a joyous occasion
and happy mid-summer to all of you guys
happy mid-summer fertility baby
how are you baby
oh you think that's why jimmy asked me
if i had taken my viagra maybe
he knew it was mid-summer little shout
out to him so weird
he did that last time too but he like he
opened with that
like we like connected and before he
even said hi to ethan that's his gag
right now
he just randomly picks one of us and
says something i always just right
absolutely wait where this is in the can
you send them on what's up the ape
photos
uh yeah i'll send that one so where did
this one go see this is a different
shirt
this is not that's an actual nft yeah
funny enough i have a shirt that looks
just like that so maybe maybe that
though is saying that maybe it is a
coincidence there's a lot of wine shirts
that look like this if abe and zach both
have a similar shirt i just found an
interesting article but what's the
because dan sent a picture of an ape and
a shirt
what's that one
that's not the actual nft
yeah again it seems to be from some uh
promotional artwork it was from a tweet
from november 15th 2021 and that was
made by them yeah it was it's tweeted by
the board a yacht club because that one
is very clearly it's the same yeah it's
the same so i think they're they were
probably smart to make the nft one a
little different
i love already yeah this is just to like
cover their eyes yeah this is for sure
the same shirt
yeah but i i guess to be fair like
boogaloo boys their thing is to wear
hawaiian shirts and i guess it's bound
to
uh
these be a couple people that has that
but it's a little bit weird with all the
other coincidences yeah again it's just
it's
it's the totality of it yeah most of
them i mean if they just wanted hawaiian
shirts there's so many colors to do it
like this typically that one this
specific one these guys wear yeah it's
all mind-bending stuff guys i don't know
but i do know i gotta go so
happy weekend to everybody thank you for
all the birthday wishes
guys thank you so much yeah happy
birthday happy birthday ethan happy
birthday
happy birthday good good thank you
you're any big plans this weekend
i'll tell you off there okay cool
yeah
all right
thanks guys
love y'all
keep your spirits up don't get too
black-pilled out there okay guys you
want to tease uh what we're doing on
monday
what is happening what's happening on
monday
[Music]
oh my mom quiz is happening one day
yeah my mom
wants to challenge so my mom goes
i know so much about monarch butterflies
you guys think of the hardest questions
you can think of about monarch
butterflies and have someone call in
and for each one she gets right we give
the caller 25 bucks
so
the success your monetary success is
dependent on how
monarch literate my mom is [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] to be fair hey [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
in her original pitch uh i don't think
she actually said give me the hardest
questions you have that was
ask me any monarch right she just kept
it general and we were we took that as a
challenge yeah of course i literally
said that's a challenge maybe no
i'm gonna send this to them
happy pride month
this must be it's been a rough one i
gotta say this is uh
been a lot of uh
bad news yeah
during pride month
but well pride is a sin as jordan
peterson
uh interestingly pointed out
yeah right
yeah pride used to be a sin
yes
you should not [ __ ] my dog you should i
love that true love is ignoring
i did not come on my dog
okay jordan well the fact that you keep
saying that is just bizarre i did not
put my dick anywhere near my dog
i've never done anything weird with my
dogs
all right dude hey listen i just work
here man
tell that to someone else
[ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
man he's really lost it
all right guys you take care it's not my
40th stop saying that
happy 40th
hey not you too
all right guys love y'all see on monday
uh have a blessed weekend
and uh remember take the blue pill guys
take or the red or
red
anything with the black pill or maybe
not the red bull blue and the blue means
stay in the matrix right and the red
pill was the good one in the movie but
now it's been appropriated maybe the
purple red pill guys purple we need a
pink pink
i'd take the pink pill you would
okay yes i think that's just called
pepto-bismol i think they have that yeah
and i'd take it i could use one of those
right now
nice
oh god what is this yeah what is that no
just a board dan
board dance or do we make a board dan uh
board dan club
let's go
[Laughter]
wait what is that basically what is that
i don't even know not even you i got far
too much hair well they put his face on
it thick
[Music]
all right i gotta go all right thank you
guys all right have a good weekend
[Music]
you